the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
the final day of Rapid chess ended in
dramatic fashion at the super United
rabbit and Blitz in Zagreb Croatia with
limited chances to gain ground players
scramble to grab critical points before
moving on to the faster time control
despite stumbling in previous rounds
former world champion Magnus Carlson
brought back winning two straight games
to get within a point of the leaders
Generations clashed as 17 year old benon
gukesh defeated his Idol viswanathan in
their first ever tournament battle
there's a tie at the top but the
ultimate wild card is hot on their heels
and ready for Blitz day four a fantastic
chess coming up next
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back chess fans to day four of
the super United rapid and Blitz held
here in Zagreb Croatia the rapid portion
ended in dramatic fashion but their
Stakes are getting higher and higher as
we start the blitz portion we have the
most dangerous and fastest Grand Masters
on the planet let's go to the studio and
see who is going to best the competition
the granchester returns to Croatia it is
rapid and Blitz action with the greatest
players in the world our live coverage
from the San Lucius club and Zagreb
starts right now
[Music]
hello and welcome everyone thank you for
joining us I'm International
and I'm here with Grandmaster yester one
wow Nasi rapid those three days of Rapid
were simply brilliant I loved it amazing
and we have two days of Blitz coming up
double round robin 18 exciting games
absolutely oh my goodness hello everyone
thank you for joining us the Rapids were
really brilliant but I was really moved
by the interview of Magnus Carlson he
may be trailing but he said in his
interview with Christian that both Abby
and nepo are going to have to have
historic best results to stop them from
winning first I tell you that's a man
who has a great deal of confidence Nasi
do the honors and tell us who is leading
in the standings let's take a look
collator
I am talking about one point behind that
Magnus Carlton in the clear third and
sharing fourth two Indian Grandmasters
vishianan and kukash
tell us about the format
we have a 10 player round robin
tournament in Rapid they had 25 minutes
plus 10 second increment right yeah in
the next two days they will play five
plus two uh
in the rapid was double scoring system
but in Blitz it's a traditional scoring
system with one point for win and half
for a draw and the players are not
allowed to offer any drugs absolutely I
gave it away there but tell us about the
remaining schedule
we have two days of very exciting Blitz
coming up we'll have around nine rounds
today nine rounds tomorrow and playoffs
if necessary as well fantastic I'm very
fortunate to have in studio our dear
friend Miro Miro tell us about the most
dangerous Blitz players on the planet
uh thank you yasa and really I can't
wait for the blitz to start we kept
emphasizing how important the rap it was
but let's not forget twice as many games
so equal number of points to be decided
in the Blitz and there's always
something captivating to watch the
strongest players compete and just to
confirm on that we do have one of the
strongest Fields possible with alireza
feruja being the top rated player on a
planet we are stocking Blitz rating
there so Four Points shy of 2900 can you
imagine Magnus Carlsen Fabiano caruana
young Christian
all in the top 10 in the world Blitz
ratings and in terms of formal
achievements Believe It or Not Magnus
Carlsen came up with a bold statement
but he has all the reason to do so six
time world Blitz champion
unimaginable achievement and then what
surprises me that vishyanand who we know
for a couple decades to be one of the
best players in Blitz has never won the
World Championship young Christian
all climbed the pedestal in one on one
or more occasions in the world Blitz
championships
so really can't wait for the blitz to
start and since we still have a couple
of more minutes let's hear from Zagreb
Christian Anastasia what what does it
look like
thanks Miro welcome back chess fans to
day four here in Zagreb Croatia this is
the first day of Blitz action the action
is getting faster and more furious and I
have to say you highlighted those world
championship titles and Magnum scores
and I mean oh my God six World titles
just unimaginable and he's confident he
showed it in the interview yesterday and
if I am nepo or Fabiano I'm definitely
looking over my shoulder behind me
because Magnus is right there in the mix
and I have to say he got a bit lucky
yesterday in the final game let's take a
look at what happened in that final game
against
yeah I mean whatever uh a lot of things
happened later but it was this also this
moment I'm not sure if you if you guys
caught it at one point after the move um
I think it was Rook to D1 Knight C5 Rook
C1 he had this move King to B2 oh my God
oh that's so disgusting yeah that's
really disgusting of course uh uh of
course I wanted to to sack The Exchange
and just win easily but
um yeah I just have A6
some sort of a study like yeah I mean
that's oh yeah that was
super careless
in the business we call that a mutual
blind spot both Players missed it you
are in the playing hole did you spot
that move Anastasia Okay Christian with
all my respect I mean to all my tactical
skills of course I couldn't even imagine
that lublesco had this great chance to
survive in that game and yes it looked
like it was just completely lost at this
moment you know also the game which
caught my attention yesterday of course
was the game between gukesh and vision
and of course all Indian fans were
following the first ever match between
them and you know gukesh outplayed his
mentor his trainer for many years and
speaking about trainers we had today a
very important event here in the same
Hotel investing Hotel the first ever
kasparagus Foundation European
conference for trainers took part here
as well together with main event
grantchester and we saw many many
important coaches
um you know who attended this conference
including of course keynote speaker Gary
kasparo himself and today the notable
coaches will make the first important
symbolic moves on the boards of the top
players of Country Store absolutely and
you mentioned we haven't mentioned him
that much in this opens but he is such a
terrifying player and yesterday when he
beat vested that was definitely probably
such an amazing feeling and one of the
pivotal moments in his career guys
amazing chess is coming your way from
Zachary Croatia back to you in Saint
Louis thank you Anastasia thank you
Christian and talk about starting with a
bang the first round of the Rat of the
blitz that's coming up let's take a look
at the pairings because it is an amazing
Perry indeed it is papiano Carolina
playing Magnus Carlson that's the one I
was talking about yes go cash playing
Richie Rapport and another amazing
matchup Anand against the promises
that'll be our backup because we'll
focus on Makar iwana versus Magnus game
in the the other two games Fairuza
against sarich and lupulasco against
Duda they're going to be fighting
they're fighting very hard for what
amount of money a lot of money they're
fighting for 100 175 thousand dollars
total in prizes first place winner is
going to win forty thousand dollars
second place thirty thousand third
twenty five thousand a price found all
the way down to 10th and final position
of seven thousand lots of grand chess
tour points up for grabs as we get ready
for round one of the Blitz
and we have half of the Marquee matchup
now Magnus has appeared late in some
Blitz Games including the world
championships for Blitz where it's three
plus two not five plus two three plus
two and he showed up two and a half
minutes late and then he still won and
he still won and there he is
hurries it on the stage
legendary figures as the trainers uh
conference in Zagreb is on their way a
lot and there you have the ECU European
Chess Union president zurab as mine uh
we called him a day a lot of legendary
players on that uh
trainers
D4 good moves are up you can let it go
es
Adrian Michael Tisha in a very very
famous trainer with Big Al Alexander
bellieski uh okay Adrian what are you
going to come up with
E4 much better nice
much better much better
than our shock Petros yeah father-in-law
of uh Peter laco
fun fact I didn't know yeah and our
Shack has been a long time trainer of
the uh pardon me the Armenian Olympic
team and won gold medals uh for Armenia
and uh much celebrated
looking good
and that she wants to take the move back
here we have Archer kogan famous
Grandmaster from Israel
okay he wants everybody
we're going to take away his senior
senior trainers title nice
h2h4 not that Spike test
something mag was my
he did it in uh the World Chess Hall of
Fame we had the candle
exhibition where we play chess with
candles the burning the burning boards
it was called and his opening room was
h2h4 it was playing right next to me
that's like
dude
you're feeling okay
he likes to experiment with just
something else because he does
they're off they're off and again we've
got nine rounds of Blitz coming up
so we're going to be focusing on Fabiano
magnus's game absolutely the round one
like on the screen we're seeing
we've got the wrong word yeah we've got
the wrong direction yeah
we've got the wrong board on this one
and there you go this is the one we
wanted to focus on Queen's Gambit
accepted
with uh
E4 E4 and B5 and Magnus looks a little
bit bored like been there done this
bishop B7 I know I think this is already
quite rare
yes
yeah the the way they've gotten
themselves into this position takes on
B5 Knight C3 Bishop takes C4
let's go five plus two I'm really used
to the the the the time controls of
three plus two that extra two minutes
can give you a false sense of security
you know that uh
but
still not a lot of time right now this
whole system that black is playing at
first blush you think you know you
really can't be doing this you're giving
white a great deal of Tempe in the sense
that once I played the moves Bishop G5
and Knight E5 uh I'm fully developed and
you've still got a lot of issues to deal
with
except there's really not that many
targets that uh
that white can can focus upon what would
you say about double pawns on B2 and B5
they're actually kind of cramping the
pawn on B5 is actually really a kind of
a useful Pawn as it prevents C7
pardon me yes C7 C5 attacking the pawn
Center comfortable development of Knight
on c6s exactly Bishop to G5 you want to
play 95 coming up next and at certain
point after you've played Knight D7 to
play the move A7 A6
so we'll see uh at first I don't really
like what Magnus has done but then again
you know looking at the position you say
if you're white where do you focus
your attention it's not that easy to
come up with a good answer probably
Center for now right uh H6 putting the
question to the bishop would you draw
back to H4 or would you like have four
more
okay because the pawn on C7 is a bit of
a Target exactly and there is after all
the half openc file but okay H4 I was
going to say queen D3 Rook D1 maybe even
bring our Bishop back to C2 trying to
put a battery on the long diagonal well
not the long diagonal so if Magnus plays
97 now which he has would you play 95
right away and
exactly yes I would and I do it for a
very specific purpose I had this
horrible feeling if I don't play Knight
takes F7 and start sacrifice start
making those sacrificial threats right
away well black will slowly slowly just
start trading and all my initiative will
taper a knight to D7 okay Bishop g3 at
First Sight looks compelling but then at
the end of the day you have to ask
yourself what is my Bishop going to be
doing on G3 not greater than G3 but
exchanging only helps black develop more
exactly right now Black's position is a
little bit cramped but if we took only
seven Queen E7 Rook d8 black has
resolved all the issues exactly and with
the move Bishop D3 uh essentially what
that move is saying is your king is
still a little bit vulnerable thanks to
this Pawn on E5 there's no Knight F6 so
it may look like it's going to take me a
while but Queen here Rook here Bishop
back to B1 Queen goes to C2 and I've got
a Checkmate on H7
it's a long-term plan but it is a plan
black has to come up with an answer
maybe 95 now good move
try to exchange some more pieces to get
more space exactly Knight D5 also has an
idea trying to force a queen trade with
a knight to B4 I think after Knight D5
I'm still going to play Queen E2 and uh
you asked me before yeah I would drop my
Bishop back yeah uh you asked me about
my double pawns on B5 and and B2 for the
moment once again I do see them as
actually cramping uh
Black's Queen side and stopping you know
in C6 and
and so on
that was move I didn't consider but of
course it makes sense
to trade off those trade up to Queens
and get his Queen maybe on the king side
one thing I might just add is that if
you do a
if you do trade on G3 like takes on G3
hsg3 any ideas of rovers are just
stopped right you know you go Queen E7
Rook deal there is some potential for
Rook A4 in the future and that kind of
ah that kind of a Rover good point that
actually does exist
and queen E7 and I do think that uh
Magnus is prepping uh Rook to d8 so that
again he'll be ready uh to run if
necessary Knight E4 so now do you think
Fabi should still play on the king side
or maybe focus on the sifa open A and C
files
you had your Rook already on A5 Rook to
A5 and Rook to A1 that makes a lot of
sense but I
the move Knight E4 Intimates to me that
he's still looking to leverage uh this
Pawn for an attack whether it be with
Knight F6 check ideas but again we've
been speaking about uh Bishop to B1 and
queen C2 for everything now black will
have the safety net with code King f8
and maybe
not getting checkmated right away
yeah uh Rook to D1 Rook okay that
definitely puts the kibosh on any ideas
of Rook A5 and doubling Rooks against
the spawn so Rook D1 prepping Bishop B1
and queen C2 maybe black should just
double on D file now
Rook D5 somehow has my
look at this King f8 I mean before you
even realized you had an attack he's
already making uh
room for his King so when the queen
lands on H7 it won't do any damage yeah
okay that's Queen won't land on a second
exactly uh if we do Play Bishop B1 I
think the idea here is Magnus wants to
trade play Rook d8 and keep hacking
things off Queen C2 okay that's putting
the queen
we haven't been guessing there most
lately
no uh this one's a bit of a surprise
because it shows it tells me he wants to
play Knight C5 sorry not at the same
time it walks into 95 night before ideas
exactly so night okay so I'm thinking 95
Knight C4 I'm trying to justify the
night before Queen C3
Knight D3 Knight D3 and we're gonna play
Bishop versus knight and I'm gonna like
Flex Bishop I mean white snide is great
on C5 as well great blocks Bishop on D5
will be just is good I agreed again so
black is okay absolutely
I'm going to agree with you until I stop
but yes uh Queen C2 I didn't expect that
now we have Rook D5
Knight C3 so the move Knight E4 didn't
impress and Fabi basically said yeah I
didn't get anywhere with that uh By The
Way We Now understand why King is on f8
sorry both players are now under a
minute and a half now so that went fast
that five minutes went by really fast so
here I'm starting getting a little bit
nervous I mean black is uh ready to
double the Rooks and maybe with Queen C5
start taking an initiative maybe it's
time to play Bishop E4 and start hacking
uh pieces off the board
Bishop F1
okay that still says I'm ambitious maybe
now if Rook d8 I'll exchange one pair of
Rooks and put the other Rook on A1 and
still go for the A7 weakness
because there is this yeah uh kind of
okay you re recapture with the Rook
there is an idea of Queen to C5 uh
attacking the pawn on D4 making put on
E5 yeah
and again queen queen is lurking lurking
wanting to play Queen H7 but I think
Queen C5 is his idea he's done it this
one we could guess
uh how do we defend the E5 Pawn exactly
and that was if you do go rookie one now
we can understand why Magnus uh captured
on E1 this would be giving up default
now it's locked and put the other Rook
on d8 and because I slightly start to
like Black's position more indeed and
this Queenie too burying the bishop
um yeah I'm not a big fan King E7 Rook
d8
looks like black has done a great job
actually in terms of solving his
problems A5
well I like that he takes advantage of
the perfect
studies the Bishops exactly blocked yes
Magnus just notices everything
I remember Tony miles accused Gary
Kasparov as being an a monster with ten
thousand eyes that he sees everything uh
Bishop takes F1 and now Rook takes F1
okay giving up
and again slightly better now yeah you
can't play Queen H7 because the e-pawn
is hanging so once again if you play
rookie one The Rook is coming oops
excuse me apologies Rook is coming to
deep whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa my Spidey
senses
what is that maybe I don't see any
tactics
down to 20 seconds Magnus 30 33. and by
the way this queen E1 an indication that
uh things have gone wrong and suddenly
black is the one
who sees the initiative I love this move
Queen to D4 absolutely now black
Knight's gonna come into the play as
well just getting out of that fork
potential Knight B5 I'm thinking Queen
takes B2 I take C7
indeed
Rook Texas
rank uh Knight to D5 I mean okay I can't
take the Knight because the Rook is
hanging The Rook is hanging but can I do
rookie two and then take one before
is
probably some toxic there yeah maybe he
is afraid of Queen I'm not sure but uh
he he decided to put his King back
players are down to 10 seconds things
are hitting up
okay and we we do have Queen takes E5
and Rook E1
by the way breaking news Fairuza started
a blitz portion of this tournament with
a win he won his game and here what's
happening so Magnus is apapon
very very nice and the time it's all
about the clock suddenly six seconds
each
we had another result already on a
network through their games
um and yeah this is this should be a
draw but with this time control exactly
Anything Can Happen very easy for Fabi
to not find the most accurate moves oh
but he's gonna Queen ending and the
queen name is easier much much easier a
little surprise that Bobby did not play
the move F2 F3
this is a slight okay nah I mean it's
it's it's very much a draw
but Magnus is very tricky he's not gonna
give up that easy no he he loves to
grind and G3 making a little bit of the
space
it's hard to make any progress though
because if he pushes another Pawn then
his King will be very much exposed to
all the Perpetual checks exactly Queen
on D4 posting up that's a very nice move
Bobby's doing an amazing job defending
this game
clock times once again five seconds for
Magnus six for Fabi at the moment he's
still thinking okay and let's not forget
they only have two second increment
that's exactly and you you don't build
up time with only two seconds but you
know tossing a few checks play Queen D4
defending the pawn on F2 making sure
well Magnus is doing his best he's
trying to squeeze his King to the effort
and move with two SEC Magnus with one
second he no way
it's really taking big risks oh he sure
has but I think now we have perpetual
well you can take on E3 take on E3 okay
so if the game goes on for sure
Queen H we just said you can't build up
time man this one from one second to ten
seconds we did it Queen to G4 no he's
running away with his King I think
theoretically even if white loses the G3
point it's still literal but of course
very difficult to make that right it's
something that you wouldn't want to try
to defend that's for sure with no time
on the clock either
yeah they both build up time but oh by
the way Queen G4 with the thread of f4
but there's no four Queen eight seven
mate careful Magnus
by the way Madness almost missed
slapping the clock there
it's nerves at this point of the game
King G6 and you kind of reset yourself
here so I'm curious if they continue to
play this game for more than 50 moves
how do you claim a draw in
in this type of game well first of all
that's a very very good question and you
can make a faulty claim the claim is not
allowed then your opponent just gets
some extra time on the clock but it's a
good way of of knowing you know what you
have to do by the way King H3 would have
walked into G4 so that was a very
and also want to mention all the other
games have finished school cash has
defeated Richie report and this is the
only game remaining
oh boy did we pick the right one what a
marquee game this has been
Again
difficult to make progress though I do
you think Magnus has a chance to trick
Fabi here yes because there
there's always this idea of sneaking the
king to the G4 square but I think Magna
should have put his Queen on
I wanted to say E2 in order to play King
H5 to G4 you know table bass showed up
and says it's winning for black I don't
know why
it really which one looks exactly the
same as before but wow okay we won't
even try to understand these these Queen
endings are really difficult but there's
a check and suddenly where do you go
with the King if you go to H2
uh Queen F2 and there goes the pawn but
if I take one G3 do I have a crazy yes
you do
not anymore Queen G4 but you had Queen
E8 check and King eight Queen H5
unbelievable Magnus manages too once
again trick Bobby
truly we still don't know where the
trick happened but now it is
seems pretty simple Yes left yeah you're
running out of out of checks King G3 and
there you go wow
well Magnus said it that you know Fabi
and nepo are gonna have to have the
tournaments of their lives to stop him
he wins with black but uh Miro and form
is what happened in the rest of the
games we're just catching our breath
over this one
yeah it's unbelievable win by Magnus at
the very end and yeah there was no
stalemate interestingly but you'll
probably check it later so I was paying
attention to the other games and yeah
there was a draw between Anand and nepo
but it seemed that both Players missed
chance to win at some point so just
quickly it's so annoyed A variation and
we remember Anand was struggling against
the Knight of Wiz white right so he went
for Bishop B3 which is a you know not
the most popular line and in a few more
moves forget the night of we have
something very typical for a dragon
Sicilian and opposite castles you know
in attacks and so on so that's how a
position looked after move 13 uh White
he's going to exchange the bishop push
the pawns attack this King this king is
already not safe and well and let us
teleport to say this position so
exchange on B5 cb5 Queen B6 and this is
where she went wrong because he captured
on D6 and it actually shifts in Black's
favor and instead he had to play H4 just
push the pawns and if black say tries to
win the B Pawn uh H5 and the attack is
very dangerous computer really likes
white here so after which he captured
takes on B5 Queen D3 it's in Black's
favor and Jan slowly slowly was cruising
towards Victory and they've swapped the
Queens at some point the resulting end
game looks equal but no it's in Black's
favorite those spawns which were good in
the middle game now they are targets and
yeah and at some point let me find the
exact moment some around here now
earlier yeah this one this one is
winning for black computer says and Jan
just missed one tiny detail there is one
more open file so he could have gone
Rook h8 then Rook H2 Rook H3 are the
threats while it turns out the Knight is
nicely placed on G5 guards F7 attacks F3
so this is much better for black uh
later on of the maneuvering maneuvering
maneuvering and at that point it was
already one only move for black to save
the game and yeah uh Jan found it so a
check here King E3 white piece is
arguably better place but then Knight G2
and you can't really go to F2 because
Rook D2 happens you go back and it's a
check and perpetual and they've agreed
to draw I believe both missed some
chances and let's look at one more game
good cash and vehicle Report Alika in
defense well if anything my favorite
opening from the childhood
black of course takes a lot of strategic
Risk by playing this
uh surrender is the center so so far so
good after move eight C4 is the most
challenging move C3 was played it's a
modest move and black usually has no
difficulties equalizing which he did and
after say move 20 we are looking at the
position which is probably slightly
favorable for black and then this is
where gukash magic starts because
because you know they've reached the end
game and absolutely equal line game and
then slow by slow little by little as
they say he outplays Rapport entirely uh
over here it's still fine and takes
takes Rook gets in 92 you start feeling
that the p7 is in danger A6 is in danger
right and he went on to win and I'll
just highlight the very last moment
where uh report could have could have
fought so this is still fine Knight D7
why it's better but not one the game
just yet and rookie 7 happens to be a
terrible blunder because after Rook C7
Rook C7 is a double attack not only the
bishop is attacked but there is Knight
B6 Knight F6 and yeah the rest did not
matter went to win the game and to other
games I believe we have Christian
Carrillo analyze for us so let's let's
hear from Christian let's hear from
Zagreb
thanks Miro I am here with Anastasia we
did analyze some of the games that you
guys didn't have a chance to look at
Anastasia why don't you start
was the police could game against young
Christoph Duda turned out to be not so
exciting I must say because it was just
like really like one of those
Grandmaster draws they played nimitzo
went for the line with this three and
later on many movies later like they
actually simply all the pieces were
exchanged as you can see and now we
entered the very very important ending
we can we can show it to this critical
moment when Queens have been exchanged
and now it's night against bishop and
you know that in Blitz night values more
it's dangerous it's a very dangerous
piece it's very dangerous but I must
admit that nothing really happened in
this particular game and after many many
moves again all bones like black was
getting a little bit yes and he put
actually all the pawns to the red
squares to the dark squares you know
showing that this bishop is not so
elective anymore but it's okay white
defended well against the Knight and at
the end of the day the game finished it
was a very normal result I mean never
ever in this in this position never
White had better work and better chances
so both players played perfectly and the
game finished in the draw the result was
definitely never in doubt now let's take
a look at this game between alireza and
Ivan sarich and let's not forget alireza
is one of the players that Magnus touted
as probably the most dangerous player in
Blitz also if I'm not mistaken I think
he's number one in Blitz alireza right
in the live rating list yes in the live
reading list perhaps something actually
nothing could have happened because he
did win this game so maybe he extended
his League take a look at this one and I
have to say in the rapid portion against
Ivan Savage we remember that game from
yesterday when Yvonne had a draw in the
last few moments unfortunately for Ivan
this was a very straightforward Affair
and it felt like white had the advantage
from the get-go he played with black
pieces took some chances played the
king's Indian defense but unfortunately
you cannot do that at this level and
you're gonna get punished well at least
it seems so remember
foreigners are giving when they start
with King's Indian defense given his
memories fond memories about the Kings
so sorry she still decided to go for it
and Fairuza probably felt happy yes at
this moment and at this point already
white has a great Advantage you build up
the center you have the better Pawn
structure and you have so much space
advantage and this is so important also
take a look at that pawn on A6 such a
powerful Pawn you cannot touch that pawn
and I'm block blocking cementing that
weakness on A7 in any sort of end game
I'm going to get my Bishop on the G1 A7
diagonal I'm going to put enough
pressure on the pawn on A7 most likely
I'm going to pick that up and the a pawn
is going to be a tremendous weapon so he
decided to sacrifice upon no longer
wanted to stay uh passive with the move
Knight to these 7 understandably so
yes you're trying to use your chances
you cannot stay tested for all the game
yesterday exactly I think it was a good
try that's a very good point and uh
after Knight takes E4 he got some
chances because the Knight comes back
into play much more
um accurate would have been Rook takes
E4 but it's not so easy to play Rook
takes E4 when you can just get the
knight in that center it's a better move
yes it was a better much better move
because Knight to F5 is no longer
possible I'm going to exchange that and
I'm also having ideas of Rook takes
before after before so
yes yes you're upon down and the
compensation Knight xc4 Knight to F5 and
I have to say this was a critical moment
um and a test for alireza because if you
play something like Queen to E2 or
anything of that nature this Knight can
land on D4 the black space is still
getting very active and this no longer
is that easy okay the bishop G7 is still
quite passive but it defends critical
squares this and I never will be able to
jump to F6 quite important but what he
played was the best move in the position
Queen to A4 and this sets up a very
beautiful trap in which unfortunately
Yvonne fell Rook takes C5 look at this
beautiful sacrifice right your check
amazing white king wow King to H1 you
want to play Rook Rook takes D2 Knight
takes D2 Knight to G3 and now you want
to give the Checkmate right of course
you want yes and that lists you have it
seems like um Perpetual checklist it's
very very beautiful by the way check
check
unfortunately after taking if you do
take on uh D2 after Queen to E8 is game
over ah so this important intermediate
move yes he missed it he uh now he's
just a rook down nothing can be done
after that he just went on to win you
should show what is the difference yes
so now for example King G7 and if not no
no I'm just I just take the bishop
immediately that's a check okay guys
back to you in St Louis thank you
Anastasia thank you Christian let's take
a look at the standings after one very
eventful round of Blitz uh things have
changed a lot now we have a soul litter
yeah finish it but only half Point
behind are two players Magnus Carlson
and Fabiano caruana you're looking over
your shoulder at Magnus and what about
our parents coming up for the second
round of Blitz all right we have Magnus
Carlson playing Duda okay sarich against
lupulasco and that punish against firoza
boy I tell you that's a tough one should
we what should be our Marquee match up
Magnus Duda nepo ferrugia it's tough I
wish I could do both but I think we have
to go with Magnus okay he's the man to
watch uh Rockford against Anand and
Carolina will be playing for cash as we
get ready for this round two of Blitz
coming up
it that game of Fabiano it just seemed
like Fabi just slip slip slip it was
just slowly slowly Drip by drip
something went wrong and it's very
depressing because as
it's a dream it's happening and you also
know you're about to lose yeah but
you're slipping and you still feel like
I I should be able to save this uh time
became a very big factor too I think at
one moment that we're down to just one
seconds yeah each I I mean and Miro can
you please show us was there any
stalemate ideas at the end
all right yeah I mean if you allow me
just 10 seconds it's uh you know not
only Fabi was fighting well and
everything but he's got unlucky because
the king is in stalemate right just get
rid of the queen right and it's a draw
but regrettably after this check why a
black has King G4 you would think this
check but King F4 and now whenever you
try to give the queen away it's captured
with the queen and the king is no longer
stalemated Queen F3 it's gonna be Queen
F3 and so on and so on so I believe he
was relying on this queen takes G3 and
it's a helmet and everything and you
just cannot get rid of the queen
thank you and they again and they are
off Magnus uh having trouble with his
chair earlier in the Rapids uh you know
he threw his chair out you can't get
comfortable and
and we have D4
looks like maybe
cool
and the open uh line of the Catalan
language D takes C4 and A7 A6
all Theory
standard stuff so far
exactly
so Nepal first time for the first time
he is in solid you know and I feel
really really good for for nepo because
he's had some results after the the
world championship match itself you know
it was he was so close the title was in
his hands then Bucharest was the
disaster after and uh to see him back on
top it's great
actually we should switch and watch this
game because I find their opening
fascinating
what was it uh yes it was fantasy
variation again but second move F3
right slightly different move order okay
and
H4 H5 yeah I'm not familiar with any of
these ideas h4h5 here it feels like the
players are definitely freewheeling uh
in this one takes on D4 yeah as if
they've seen this before well I'm
guessing they have but it is it does
feel completely new uh for me as well
first
impressions as black as doing fine I
mean this bishop B6 uh looks really good
to my eyes you know this Pawn on D4 this
Knight is ready to jump to E5 so if you
play for example 94 95 I don't see why
why black isn't a happy camper no I like
that because we
already
if White Castles short there's so many
weaknesses on the king side indeed that
pawn will immediately uh
would be very happy if they could jump
the queen from D1 to anywhere else just
so they could cast along right but
that's not possible and it will take way
too many moves to develop the queen and
cast along I just don't even know what
I'm supposed to do here with with in
nepo shoes because I don't want a castle
short for the reasons that you mentioned
including the fact that I've got my Pawn
on H5 so I have to make room for my
queen he did play Knight F4 but then you
asked yourself well what exactly is my
knight doing on that four Knight is
coming to E5 this other night is coming
either to F5 or D5 and it just feels
like the coordination is wrong I agree
and also even if white manages to Castle
long black also has open B file so I can
play Rook B8 and I will have some ideas
on the B file for sure no question about
it 95 immediately
I'm not exactly sure why farrugia is
resisting Knight E5 but there is there
is an issue yeah the the the king is uh
on the IFA the other thing
if you don't take on D5 and double up
the Pawns
you know you're well I mean
I think white might be okay here with
King on F1 yeah that's what I was
thinking with just the double pawns the
problem is I don't want to take but I
don't want to allow rookie 8 and Knight
E3 when I'm thinking that pawn on E3
might live and that would be very very
bad news this is the current position
clock is a factor ah Fiero is looking
very good he has four minutes and Eon is
down to two and a half minutes so
definitely why it didn't get uh anything
out of the opening if anything
black is definitely better already so
our tournament leader nepo uh facing his
first challenge of the day uh here as
far Asia starts with a win and well in
Blitz nobody's higher rated and Magnus
did mention yesterday the only player
who has the most potential in the blitz
is firusha he said right
Queen E2 after I want to say kind of a
long think I'm just going to refresh my
board wow Queen E2 and G4 was not expect
I guess he's stopped in F5 but that's
what it's all about right it's just
it looks very risky in Knight C5 Maybe
five I love I like that move a lot
I've also just some for some reason I've
got 95 on the brain
focusing on that Bishop but Knight C5
does the same thing and maybe what you
were saying about Rook B8 and Knight A4
potential of attack against the pawn on
B2 I like Knight C5 it it gives that
option the additional
a chance
Bishop C7
oh that's annoying move force in White's
night to either trade or step back well
if I step back there is a bishop G3
check that could be disruptive I can't
take on day five minutes I definitely
cannot take on D5 that's right the move
G4 right now I'd like to play the move
G3 and protect the night night went back
to H3 I guess if Bishop G3 check now
push is planning to play King F1 King G2
of course it's unpleasant but it's it's
not the end of the world well here we go
I wasn't sure about King F1 I thought he
might even want to go not that I want to
play uh King D1 let's just jump back to
the game of Magnus uh for a moment
Magnus versus Duda let's see what
happened well we won't go too far back
but it does feel like he's up in
exchange exchange for a pawn what upon
yes those are two connected past pawns
at the moment gosh uh what do they call
that line
but since he's blocking the pawns okay
four yeah
Queen I would say that it's game over at
all
those uh those two connected past pawns
you don't want to underestimate the
power of the pawn C5
I like that move that's a good uh
fighting back type of move Queen to D1
intimating that uh
the damage King side it might allow for
Queen G4 check
ERS so good
for now
there yeah you're kind of committed to
blockading uh so I'm not sure how strong
White's advantage
serious well we want to take and play
Queen D4
and let's say I play King fa just like
Magnus did earlier king cafe I take on
C5 you take I say I go Queen D4
played F5 so if we do take and go Queen
D4 the pawn on F6 isn't hanging but I'm
thinking that I want to play Rook A1
asab
and that's why I wanted to trade Queens
on D4 so I can play D5
I think D5 right now is also interesting
I know I'm giving you three connected
platforms but I'm creating one for
myself I understand so D5 takes takes
Rook d8 yeah and then E4
because I really want to open up e-file
and if I can choose my Rook so I mean I
have the feeling that you do that uh now
see and it's sort of like a lot of uh
bridges are being burned h4h5 okay
possibility of H6 and setting up some
mating patterns maybe age six if I'm
black uh to get out of that to prevent
agency I think I would not want to allow
white to play H6 exactly
H6 Dundee takes sick and queen D4 still
looks like a good option right
yeah this is still
early to say I still think it's three
results I mean I I I I do like the
exchange for you know
exchange up but uh yeah but I think our
tournament literally is going down in
his game oh really so we'll we'll switch
back we'll flip back to the game between
nepo and farrugia because we saw it when
we left it with Bishop G3 check and then
he ended up playing King F1 and let's
jump to the current position
it goes down to two so I can suggestions
this is not happiness D3 is hanging with
check and guess what he took it
yeah this is and the clock should be
completely winning for black uh fiduci
has two minutes and that puts down to
four seconds
oh we can grab another Pawn maybe and
let's do it yeah you know Queen takes B2
the Harvest is in in full bloom here now
White's position is absolutely
depressing and I think there is Rook
takes E4 hanging and then Bishop D2
trading everything yeah yep Rook takes
E4 certainly looks good
for it
got a good opening out of the opening
and
what's the black pieces that's here for
the car economy there goes a third pawn
and napo's had enough let's jump back to
the game of Magnus our congratulations
to farrugia knocks off the tournament
leader and uh I'm not going to say
anything but I do believe he was your
pick
uh F4 G4 whoa whoa whoa who is attacking
whom F4 G4
see I think Anastasia mentioned earlier
that in Blitz Heaven Knight is a very
dangerous thing because Knights are very
tricky yeah and I would actually rather
be black in this position I was about to
say Knight C6 if it provokes the move D5
the Knight would jump to D4 and then F3
check is on tap so that was why Magnus
played the move Rook E4 he didn't want
to see the Knight but then came B3
it is very strange to say that white is
using the major pieces Queen and two
Rooks to defend the pawns exactly uh we
just saw the movie E5 so after D4 oh
instantly Duda Duda is playing like hey
I'm the one with the attack and Magnus
is saying no wait a minute I've got
attacking ideas as well look at my
potential Queen F6
speaker
and the clock times clock times Magnus
has an advantage he has 30 seconds and
dudas has only five seconds
he has to five seconds instantly King G2
okay uh F3 check looks good I don't know
if it threatens anything but well he's
got to do something
Knight D4 comes in with a check and
maybe I can take 26 with it
and somehow uh survived that okay King
takes F3
and he's done King looks safe with the
Knight on E6 say for safer for sure
Magnus C5 oh Queen takes B3 that was
bigger the B3 Pawn that that was a big
big Pawn should have played Queen B5 and
kept the pawn alive
by the way he's stepping into a nasty
pin is Duda Queen B8 check King H2 I
love that by the way clock times in just
a few seconds
oh
yeah
in just last few moves and we've got the
remaining game uh Fabi and gukash
oh it looks like he's winning he's up to
actually pretty easy but the clock times
four seconds to six seconds yeah okay F5
let's go
the king side and yeah this should be
game over
yeah it's because five is up two pawns
while it's winning otherwise there was
always The Rook exchange option seven
but hey Google
comes back after a loss that was a huge
win actually uh because he he kicks down
a rival uh do we have any other games
yes
uh maybe a rapport oh Rapport defeated
Anand
okay very very nice there is one game
still going on sorry
Drew okay uh so four decisive games wow
I'm still uh nepo versus farugia and
Magnus winning uh but Miro uh jump in
what have we missed in round two uh wow
you didn't miss anything you seem to
cover all the important games uh well
let me tell just a little bit in detail
for this one Magnus against Doula so how
did we get to this very sharp position
with an extra exchange first of all this
is a known position right black indeed
tries to not only to take on C4 but so
save this pawn and there are many many
moves Bishop E3 is the rare one that's
what magmus chose the bishop D7 Queen to
C1 attack the pawn B5 B3 and now it's a
real Pawn sacrifice you're no longer
winning the pawn back it disappeared
right but this is a very well-known
structure where white usually has the
compensation for the pawn so in few
moments we are reaching this type of
position so white has semi-open C file
as well as a file a very nice Square on
C5 where the knight's gonna land in few
moves so white usually has enough
confrontation for equality but not more
than that right so H4 Queen B6 E3 A5 and
this was a mistake by Young Christoph
Doda after which Knight C4 shifts the
scales in White's favor for now but then
capture sculptures night to F6 they've
swapped takes takes here indeed white is
better and then immediately magnus's
Rook A4 is not the best right and it's a
very very complex position so perhaps we
shouldn't care much what the engine has
to say up to this point it's very sharp
and relatively uh correct what players
have done F3 is a brilliant move in fact
one of the few moves that really keep
Black's position afloat and King F3 the
move Magnus played was a terrible
mistake instead he should have gone King
G3 after King F3 Knight D4 it's black
who's better and then King G2 Knight E6
C5 and queen C6 is a terrible terrible
mistake and in fact after Queen B5 it
could have went upside down dude I was
waiting after Queen B5 right and just to
mention poor lupulasco he had absolutely
winning position against storage but
then once again couldn't convert it and
well viewers the crew will let Christian
have a few words I think he analyzed the
other games so Zagreb to Christian
Anastasia
we did analyze a couple of games I will
let you once again Anastasia start with
the analysis you looked at this game
between Richie and Robert and it was
absolutely crazy game reversed benoni
and both of them were playing very
creative we showed this critical moment
where white managed to push before one
of the main ideas in this line of course
and after that I mean it was of course
crazy uh Knight ended up at the end on
C3 trying to block response so at the
end it was like both both sides were
trying to come first yes at um by this
trend of course to Queen and then also
black managed to get some counter play
and push their pawns very far away yes
and many times richer had seemed like
winning position but he didn't bring the
final blow and I would say that was in
just a moment here Queen the eight I
mean white could play maybe the queen of
seven and if you take take then I mean
King just comes there and the ending is
winning but he didn't do it and he won
at the end on time you know so in this
position which already looks still
dangerous for black of course but most
stable absolutely maybe winning but
still if you need to do some work you he
managed to win I think after age six
Queen E7 King to G2 and unfortunately he
just didn't make the last move on time
nice victory for Richie report let's
take a look at what happened in uh that
game that you guys caught up with
Fabiano versus gukesh because we know
Fabiano has some problems with good cash
Gucci bit him in a blitz in Norway he
bit him in the rapid as well take a look
at this ponziani when is the last time
you've seen the ponziani attack as white
knight to F6 D5 is obviously also an
idea Knight F6 D4 and now D6 this is
very passive and allows white to get the
advantage and this is exactly what
Fabiano did just take more and more
space and uh to be honest it was just a
very smooth game by Fabiano Nito G5 get
the Knight on E6 of course you cannot
take it because if you do that you're
going to lose a queen so you have to go
Rook to F7 but this is just such a sad
position you don't have any counter play
thank you
it's time to fight for titles the best
juniors girls and Senior chess players
converge in the chess capital of America
St Louis Missouri for the U.S junior
girls and Senior championship
beginning July 15th 30 players will
compete across three fields for over a
150 000 prize fund
this tournament features the top Junior
and senior chess players in the nation
including the young up-and-comer Karissa
yip
Young Junior Phenom ABI Manu Mishra and
returning senior Champion Alexander
shavalov
three titles are on the line and you
won't want to miss it catch all the
action on the St Louis chess club
YouTube and twitch channels
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in-store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
in Forest Park
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomed chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody and these are our
standings after two rounds of Blitz some
changes again now we have two co-leaders
Magnus Crossing and Fabiano caruana as
Jan slips due to his loss uh Jan is in
clear a third and now Sharon fourth
firusha and gukesh yeah Ali Reza coming
up with back to back and our pairings
for this round three of Blitz coming up
should be an exciting one cash is
that's got to be our Marquee matchup
right there now backup will be Anand
against Carolina very very nice back up
indeed for Russia versus Rapport also
interesting and
win third in a row exactly nice crowd as
weekend in Zagreb how else do you want
to spend your summer weekend if not for
the grand Chester Blitz and I tell you
things move very very very fast not just
in the over the board games but the
standings Borussia started the day at
seven I think he was shared in seventh
place he's already at Fourth and the
world's number one rated Blitz player
Ali Reza faruga showing why he's number
one with back-to-back victories as we
get ready for round three uh marrow it's
been exciting stuff so far and we're
expecting more of the same yeah
absolutely and I'll be paying attention
to Yanni bomshi because he seems to have
the same struggle he had day one of
Rapid to win one in a row
one in a row yes but he did win four out
of a four in a row in the Rapids when he
did get his Mojo going he did it very
very well I think he messed up his
preparation in that fantasy with the
bishop coming to D3 earlier he should
have probably done what you said a
castle quickly along and play Queen E2
but let's see some of the action through
the magic of Television the end of the
Magnus game from the previous round
as uh this game with Duda was live at so
many moments and
there goes that first grow up
exactly if you won this game you just
lost five moves right and then there was
that moment where Duda miss queen B5
which was very strange to miss you've
just played the move Rook D1 check your
opponent's king goes to G2 well if you
can get your queen to F1 you do it you
go Queen F1 check how he doesn't play
Queen B5 I mean he does it a hundred
times out of a hundred
you sit there you play Magnus Carlson
and you find something else like we're
staying during the break Magnus is good
and lucky good and lucky so it's it's
it's a deadly combination for sure as we
get ready for this around three and
again
we are ready
and we have a special uh birthday today
who is it Leonard happy birthday Leonard
our photographer uh extraordinaire I
want to say do check out his website he
has thousands of thousands of photos
from the grand chest tours over the
years and he has a beautiful eye for
photography really uh congratulations to
Leonard also as we're saying
congratulations we want to thank our
sponsors uh very much super United
Foundation as well as Croatia's full of
life foundation and of course here in St
Louis the St Louis chess club and
Scholastic Center thank you sponsors
each and every one of you you have
presented a wonderful wonderful Grand
Chester thank you very much super United
people of Life Foundation as the players
take their seats for round three yeah I
think fear was just feeling pretty good
the day with the two wins in a row it's
nothing like a victory to make the
sunshine the birds sing he took down the
tournament leader with the black pieces
that is so huge winning is great but
taking a rival and knocking them off
their perch that's even better still
um I want to say Richie as one of those
players who's always in that the mix but
he has too much up and down he's
inconsistent but he can play and win
any single game I think it's possible
it's because of his openings because
unlike the pretty much the rest of the
field his openings are not very solid
right
I agree he he it takes a lot of risk and
as does Madness in the openings now
kukash coming up I just lost a Fabi uh
that's uh that's a setback definitely
and Magnus will
take advantage of gokesh's mood right
now right yeah
just lost a game Magnus on a tear as
he's he basically made his announcements
known yesterday uh with his bold
statement that Fabi and Napa better play
you know a historic Tournament of their
life because
he wasn't wrong not so far not so far uh
Miro in your experience and a very
experienced Grandmaster you are uh don't
you just love it when somebody makes a
bold statement like Magnus and says hey
you better have the tournament of your
life uh well yes it's not it's quite
rare for chess Community right but he as
we figured out he has all the rights to
do so well when you're a six-time Blitz
World Champion yes you do and speaking
of Robert yes I would I wish I could say
that I'm unstable and you know ups and
downs and still hover around 27.50 right
right uh timer whoa G2 G4 H6 like
immediately as if yeah everybody knows
about G4 and H4 I'm not interested in
what's going on familiar with G4
in this line I'm forcibly reminded of
the game of the park
Judith Polgar white versus Magnus
Carlson it was a time on off as well and
Judith on a free day when she's not
doing chess commentary decided it was
time to crush Magnus in a Blitz game
and I thought that was really a fun
moment Queen D2 isn't that inviting B4
my spidey sense is tingling can I take a
pawn sorry that I think so because that
was not what I wanted 95 is definitely
premature sacrifice right
apparently this is all Theory so far uh
B for you're saying Knight D5 is
particularly right so I would have to go
92 G1
okay
yeah but I mean B4 certainly before and
94. now the question is should I take
the pawn uh that's a different matter
altogether I mean I can play Knight F6
and my mistook the pawn
I love it looks like show me why exactly
well we are in Missouri for those of you
don't know this is the show me state
show me why I can't take the pawn Rook
G1 setting up for the bishop G2 and a
skewer of The Rook
C4
Queen C4 okay well he gets out of the
well the skewer yes sorry
Knight D4 he just wants to drop back to
C7 I assume six square yeah Knight D4
Queen to C7 and he's basically saying
okay I won a pawn
now you've got all the Tempe uh the
development how are you going to do it
we're on move 14 and only black piece
that's developed is the queen
usually that's something that you you
say to amateur players don't fall in
love with your queen you have other
pieces and all of those other pieces
blacks other pieces are all asleep
uh they're in the in their Barracks
Queen C7 on the board let me just put
their exceptions to all the rules that's
the problem we make these rules and we
forget they're not rules they're
guidelines yeah okay so even though
black has no development to speak of he
does have a pawn and he has no
weaknesses so what is white supposed to
do Castle okay but I'm saying long term
are you planning to play G5 or
uh like from Black sport perspective
he's going to go 97 Knight C6 Bishop E7
right just do some development uh I
would definitely play G5 and maybe even
G6 afterwards as white yeah
yeah to get G5 and G6 in so oops excuse
me so castles first or G5 first what's
your what's your pick now I like to have
my king
tucked in safely so your Castle first
okay I like it too Castle's long makes
the most sense just plated castles long
yes good for him
uh Magnus quickly played Knight F6 not
97 as you suggested
walking right into G5 but there is a
reason why he might be attracted to
Knight F6 because he does get the tempo
back he encouraged G5 HG pardon me yes
hghg Knight E4 Queen to D4 and now
there's the moment of truth right right
now should we play the move D5
we have summer moves already
I was about to say Bishop B7 makes a lot
of sense and 96
96. he's not interested in playing D5
and allowing G6 with a play against the
E6 Pawn Knight to D6 on the board okay
back yes take the pawn back
Queen takes B4 immediately Bishop G2 and
Knight F5 right I mean because of the
temporary the the Knight blocks the
bishop right look also has in between
Rook C8 move I don't know if it's
helpful or not but normally the threat
of uh Checkmate in one uh does get your
attention right so Queen takes the
problem I'm seeing just a moment Queen
takes Rook C8 could even play a move
like Queen A4 you know I can defend C2
and maybe you know
G6 Knight takes E6 ideas I'm beginning
to warm up to White's position actually
and I do like the move Queen before a
lot
if he doesn't take one before maybe he
can try G6
immediately here yeah
G6 definitely
takes B4
Rook C8 really fast this game he still
has almost four minutes on the clock and
versus good catches minute and a half 90
seconds already huge Advantage right
well that that move Queen B4 versus G6
that that was a tough one and good cash
took some time he was calculating
but in the end he decided to to
even material quality by the way Queen
on A4 is really annoying and that was
why we saw Queen C6
and things have calmed down tremendously
here how are we doing in our backup game
uh not that I'm going to move I just
wanted I think we should uh maybe we
should check with ferocious game it's
honor roll he won two games in a row and
looks like we have a very interesting
Edition currently wow
yeah just a second I'm just trying to
get the Zen of this uh
the F2 he has two pieces for three pawns
is that right
yes so he's yeah
uh yeah two pieces for three pawns the
king's a little weird but this move
Queen E1 sets up for Knight to G1 and
then you're untangling if you will
such huge material advantage that as
long as I'm not getting mated
it doesn't even matter that my pieces
are passive right uh Knight to G1 and
queen H4 on uh Ali Reza's agenda
maybe even maybe even Bishop Eve
four I was thinking also Bishop F3 Maybe
F3
yeah we're beginning there I like the
pieces because Eve is as awkwards as
these pawns are uh they're blockaded and
by the way that last move
you know you're ready to play Queen H4
Queen trade means that your king is in
safety just Knight F3 and I think King
is already safe yeah no I guess I'm
being a little too anxious I want to
just trade to get the Queens off the
board as quickly as possible Queen H4
Queen G6
I think it's important for black to
maintain some attacking chances against
the king
it's the illusion of it the illusion I
mean I need my dreams
uh by the way the Rook on B1 makes a
strange impression why is The Rook on B1
why isn't it on like A3 or doing
something the bishop on C1 needs life as
well
Queen H4 Queen G6 that that was it was
it was vital I want to say that Richie
did not trade Queen sorry I just played
through K1 he was also uncomfortable
with through Computing right exactly uh
it's not that there is a back rank mate
but Queen takes and Rook D1 would have
been awkward
no yeah now I think feroza will just put
one of the pieces on F3 Bishop order the
night so Rook F5 uh intimating Rook H5
is an idea oh so now Bishop after
actually looks very good because if you
go Rook H5 I'm happy to take Queen G4 I
have so many pieces I can give a little
bit back yes exactly I agree
wholeheartedly Bishop F3
and a talking about uh what a victory
would mean for alireza first of all
would be three in a row he started in
seventh position he's now currently tied
for fourth and with a win he would be
tied for first
oh really it happened that's it happened
that quickly I mean wow okay uh but Rook
at five I like your move Bishop F3 a lot
he played Bishop E4
oh that's a challenge there's d8 check
in case of Rook takes E4 Knight takes E4
Rook H5 there's a queen d8 check oops
and then 96 right in the queen but hold
on what is Rook takes E4 Knight takes E4
Rook takes D5 I'm trying to harass the
white king
that's probably let's see do I still
have quindeer check
so rookie 494
uh Rook D5
Queen d8 check Knight E8
H5
oh that makes it easy because
no no no more yeah now I think we just
develop
play immediately Knight F3 or take on a
five yeah I like the immediate Knight F3
what he chose because at certain moment
you're gonna have to play Rook takes E4
uh and just go all in and he's done it
problem as I see it is I can go check
and Knight to G5 and my king is actually
pretty safe right yeah not to G5 my king
is actually kind of safe I'm inviting
Rook H1
this is type of position you don't want
in back house with white
give me a pawn oh Bishop takes E3 just
stopping ideas
I may have missed that because
no I used to but he's up
material massive amounts of material
Rook G5 okay yeah okay I forgot he has
an another rookie yes exactly it is but
wait a minute there is a threat of Queen
G3 mate so Queen has to come back to H4
very quickly which he did very nice so
Richie has three seconds on the clock
feroza
if anything but it's a rook and Rook the
G2
Rook to G1 and uh alireza is going to be
on the attack again six seconds one two
two queen F3 well actually Richie has
four pawns now for federal well Queen
takes F6 oh he didn't play G2 and G
takes F and black has four Pawns
but they're pretty ugly oh no I think
what is theirs made
blunt oh my gosh hold on a bit Richie
had no time I know I'm shocked yeah
furosha just blundered made he blundered
made
wow uh
sorry uh let's just jump back into the
Magnus game and
wow we turned our backs for just the
briefest of moments let's jump to the
Magnus Carlson game because it's the one
remaining he's a pawn up and a king upon
Ending game yeah he's winning and Napa
also won his game
wait a minute I think that was uh
everybody every game was decisive no
draws and just a second king C5 no
hold on how are we supposed to oh G6
yeah
and after King D5 F6 F6 right
and there goes the flagged
so Magnus win in all three games in a
row and last game Let's jump to it as
Duda versus sarich and a queen ending
with oh equal material but a past Pawn
it's it's the bee Pawn that's the
dangerous Pawn check and and B7 yeah
I think it's lost anyways
wow all decisive games
that happened really really fast as far
Asia losing I'm in a shot because he was
a rook ahead
I and here's my pick
um Miro uh fill in some gaps there uh
well I didn't see everything well there
is a there is a lot I mean first of all
you have to confirm compute evaluation
of fairuz's game firosha was winning all
the way until he blundered but kudos to
Rapport it was if you will a sacrifice
in spirit of Mikhail tal not obviously
sound right and but but yeah he kept he
kept pushing
anyway to update you with the other
games uh do that with sarich I will not
go in detail at all just to mention that
the you know the queen end game you've
witnessed was with new Queens so it was
a lot happening just believe me right I
mean uh yeah it started as a quiet
Sicilian and then was misplayed by
sarich and then went back and forth but
eventually do the one it was a very
exciting game between Constantine
lupuscu and janipomnishipur lupolesco
still cannot score a win even though he
was close once again and nepo playing
the king's Indian and actually giving a
lesson to Magnus you only play e75 after
view castles and again same lupulasco
right I mean I'm referring to the game
yesterday in the rapid uh while they've
gotten to a typical I want to say
typical King's Indian position where
computer screaming white is better and
indeed he is but black always has some
sort of you know contemplate tricks and
so on and so on
uh right and at some point that's a
that's a key myth I really want to
highlight it so E5 E4 that's what you're
doing in the king's Indian you are ready
to sacrifice the material to make sure
your pieces are active right so Bishop
on G7 now and this bishop will play a
key role later on so the pawn after some
few more moves was taken and yeah and
even computer changes its mind here so
it says yeah white is no longer like the
position is no longer one-sided black
has his resources uh right and it went
on to shift in nepo's favor and I just
want to highlight the the final couple
of final touches so here White's tale
could have could have played with well
somewhat quirky move Queen to C3 looks
like you're almost blundering something
but black doesn't have a nice way to
jump with this Knight and what lupolescu
did he went King A2 after which Knight
F3 happened and then he played Queen C3
and guess what B2 Rook B2 finishes It
Off uh right so a bit unlucky for
lupolasco but Jan bonds is back and wins
his first in a row first in a row right
thank you for that Miro and again the
standings are shifting uh tremendously
and uh update us please Nancy now we
have mattress is so leader of the
tournament with 14 points and only half
Point behind the Annie pomnishi and
another half Point behind Fabiano
caruana but the rest of the field kind
of fallen behind exactly there is
they're they're making uh gaps and let's
jump to a Zagreb with Anastasia and
Christian
thanks guys well we will be following a
couple of games and the one that I chose
is the one between alireza and richen on
the live rating list alireza was
actually touching 2 900 once again after
his victory in the past game
unfortunately for him he's back below 2
900 after that accident against Richie
report and I have to say what a crazy
game that was take a look at the
beginning of that one alireza with the
white pieces Richie rapport with the
black pieces Richie already inviting a
very uh serious battle with his D6 E5
taking the center I mean this is not how
you play generally classical jazz yes
Blitz you can play anything whatever you
want yes H4 Knight to F6 and take a look
at this moment uh this is the moment
that I want to highlight after the move
A4 Knight to G4 Knight to H3 in fact it
paid off uh the gamble by Richard with
the black piece is definitely paid off
because right now he has more or less a
better position if he doesn't take on D5
and I think this is important because
once you exchange this couple of Pawns I
also have the idea of Knight to B5 as
white I have some extra squares it's
very very important instead of that
probably Bishop to F6 would have been
the better move just played slow Bishop
two is F6 Queen to E7 maybe centralize
the queen get the bishop to D7 get the
other Rook on uh EA just a typical plan
but take it slow instead of that he took
took E3 and this was a critical mistake
after F3 unfortunately he's just
completely lost he has a couple of
options he can go back and accept the
fact that I'm just simply going to be a
pawn down absolutely no compensation and
probably from a strategical point of
view white is also batters or you can
just go crazy Bishop H4 Bishop takes H4
which is this style this is Richard of
course I'll calculated everything you
said a you have to say B give another
piece sure I'll take it
down a few pawns sure three pawns and
some attack but I have to say firusha
did play some very good moves I to G1
get the Knight to F3 blockade everything
and unfortunate but unfortunately for
him as you guys saw it and by the way
hey bishop to E4 once again the same
idea do you want to try to avoid any
sort of uh trades or do you just give up
the exchange he gave up the exchange
there's so much material down right now
and white has a completely winning
position but unfortunately for him he
fell through the cracks that big
accident at the end where he allowed
Checkmate and both of the players were
pretty much smiling about this game when
I started which one were you watching
kind of feel yes when it's a mess on the
board so I would check the game Ananda
against Fabiano caruana it was also a
very interesting game at the beginning
it seemed to be very quiet Ray Lopez you
know then probably new Theory until move
to 30 or something like that so I will I
will jump to this moment when uh y2con
P5 I couldn't understand for the
beginning why black just don't don't
doesn't take the pawn on B5 but uh
fabric had something else in his mind he
decided to go for this type of attack
um look at this and queen F2 threatening
sometimes you know after Knight H4 some
checkmates on G1 perhaps but we should
defend it very well first he took on C1
and then he just simply moves his Queen
back and just ended up with an extra
Pawn right and which just moves so let's
just check what was happening if you go
B6 how do you get it this is Knight H4
maybe he's coming yes with the idea
Queen G1 Checkmate if you take but if
you you cannot yes and the threat Knight
F3 also is quite strong right so yeah so
he found this queen to two first you
know in order to defend against all the
threats and let's go back to this moment
and then after queen queen two it turned
out that took a black has no time for
all the tricks so he's still at Queen C5
B6 and now Knight H4 again with great
move of by Vision 92 defending G1 Square
simple as simple as that but look what
happened after it was not the end after
I moved before because let's say if you
play Queen D1 Rook B2 I mean you lose
the pawn yes but but it was still
winning for visha but he decided to play
before and look what Fabi did he
actually got some chances here because
he created also a postpone at this
moment so we started to move and I mean
black had to give up white had to give
up a couple of points after that you
know B6 but still okay D5 is pretty
strong but you can see that the amount
of Bones became suddenly equal yes and
Fabio had really good chances but then
he blundered badly somewhere here Knight
F6 computer says this is the crucial
mistake in the game with some precise
move he could still hold this position
but okay after that okay it's lost I
mean and this was the critical move
perhaps this is what he missed the fact
that sure you cannot touch unfortunately
this Knight because that's a check and
you cannot take the queen unfortunately
nice win by vicious
exactly yes he'd start well and now they
Victory maybe will cheer him up day
three in Rapid lost against good cash
this one wasn't the greatest of starts
but this is an important uh Victory and
um we're going to go back to the studio
in St Louis thank you Anastasia thank
you Christian things are happening so
fast we don't get a chance to get it in
but let's just check in with our friends
at Q Boutique to see what the special is
for today it is a puffy vest gear up in
the newest apparel from the St Louis
chess club with this officially branded
puffy vest features the chess club
signature logo across the left press
pocket and by the way I do like these
puffy vests they're very very comfy to
wear as we take a look at our standings
through three rounds of Blitz Magnus
Carlson in the lead let's see if someone
can catch him Yanni promise she only
half Point behind and Fabiano caruana in
the clear third now we see how important
a victory for this she was tell us about
the pairings coming up for this round
four
all right let's take a look we have
Magnus Carlton playing Ivan sarich who
is not having the best tournament no
he's had positions he's had
opportunities he just hasn't realized it
the partnership playing Duda important
game two Romanian Grandmasters facing
each other rapper lookalasco caruana and
ferrous are both coming to this round
from the loss exactly a big big game
going on there and then the all Indian
matchup between gukash and vishi and Nan
and by the way it's a kind of a nice
moment to reflect on the fact that we're
Mentor in the grand chest tour we've
just finished the Rapids and let's
remind everybody where we stand in the
grand Chester standings So currently
Wesley so is leading the granchester
and The Duda is in the second place 5B
in third but if we take a notice at the
events played exactly Bobby
has more chances right exactly well he's
going to get more than two points so he
will certainly bounce past Wesley and
again for Duda dudas playing in his
third event which also explains why he
has so many points but these are the
grand Chester's standings uh midpoint
and I want you to get in on this mural
uh three rounds of Blitz what's the
trends uh what's the trends well there
is a man who said yeah I'll score a lot
and he does that that's pretty much it
yeah well lots of ups and downs but you
know you have to be strong and lucky
that's what that's what Magnus does yes
so far seems Unstoppable very good and
the loss by farouza though so close to
2900 there's something special about
that I have the feeling though that in
his career as a Blitz World Champion
that Magnus passed the 2900 barrier as a
blitz player not as a classical player
but is at some point yeah I'm pretty
sure he did when you when you score
something like 10 out of 11.
so few players in the world have ever
passed 2900 exactly exactly as we get
ready for this round four by the way
tell me our Marquee matchup is going to
be uh
yeah Magnus Carlson will be our key
match and um nepo maybe versus Duda or
do you like Fabi versus faruga I like
them all I know I know we can only do
focus on one two three I think
okay good uh Magnus versus Yvonne
saritch it's going to be our Marquee
matchup for sure as we get ready for
this round four
players don't really have a lot of time
to rest and prepare for the next round
they just have to keep going that's what
I wanted to ask by the way uh
do they talk to their coaches or
trainers in between the games I mean
obviously they're not allowed to consult
computers or anything like that but they
are able to between the game talk to
their coaches am I right on this Murrow
yeah I think you are yeah right and I
remember some tournaments when you have
a second of a play and it would be as
well like very strong Grandmaster
remember mvl Consulting
Etienne bakron yes and after the Blitz
game he would immediately you know jump
and run and ask yeah and especially if
it's like a match at the World Cup or
something so you have to play possibly
one more game with the same color in
like half an hour so he would jump and
run what was the line he was playing
as we see Gucci
generally he's one of the earliest
players to arrive at the board and I I
think that this is an incredibly good
habit to have 17 years
young but in my mind that shows a great
deal of maturity to get there early you
get into the
the every tournament Hall has its own
special I want to say vibrations the
feelings the noises uh the staging the
lighting and if you can get yourself
comfortable with all of those things
it's going to reflect on uh on your play
and kokesh is playing Ananda again so in
the rapid when they played that was the
first time ever that they faced each
other in a real tournament exactly and
go cash one what are the chances it's a
hero Mentor that's that's really quite
special can he do it again
about to find out aren't we yeah
yeah so you just feel inconfident did
you have that experience in your life
that you had somebody who you really
looked up to and then
unbelievable to you they were an
opponent at the board twice it was
Alexandra castanoke and Nana zagnita two
extremely strong female players
Grandmasters I grew up watching their
games and one day I was lucky enough to
face them and I won both games no way
yeah so you pulled a gooketch yeah you
beat your zero it's easier to play for
me of course in this case for good cash
right
wow and for for you marrow did you ever
have that experience of growing up with
somebody who was a hero in your mind and
playing them remarkable well not really
a hero because I grew up thinking only
kind was the best right so I didn't have
a chance but but yeah I faced a few
Legend players but guess what unlike
Nazi's story I've got destroyed every
single day
it wasn't a beautiful outcome huh
as the players getting taking their
seats and getting ready for round four
three out of three Magnus two out of
three for farugia and Magnus is playing
Ivan sarich and he's looking across the
board and he's going
[Music]
I want I want this Victory streak to
continue uh Ivan sarich is not being
playing the script because he had a
chance against Magnus he could have
turned the tables in their rapid game
are we going to see another King's
Indian mirror uh well depends on
magnus's move I believe because sarich
is consistent in playing the king's
Indians right if you play one D4 here
you have it
and yeah so sarichi is not a well you
know he's not gonna back away absolutely
and it won't be easy for Magnus right I
mean he had the winning position in
Rapid and blew it up and even was close
to lose no Kings Indian for you let's go
with the Sicilian shall we play an open
system no thank you Bishop C4
let's say the Grand Prix attack but uh
um
yeah
yeah that's that could be some other
inclusion I'm not exactly sure if this
has a name other than uh well you put
your Bishop on C4 you avoid a lot of
theory
just get a playable position and that's
what Magnus wants yeah
to quote the from the musical from
America A Horse With No Name
rrna B5 now that's just tossing it out
there I like it D3 D4 so we've got our
classical Central Pawn Duo uh in the
middle of the board and Ebon is saying
you can have your classical Pawn
Advantage nobody believes you uh I'm not
so sure he's right I'm kind of like
White's position actually 52 yeah
I like the space
all right can you start playing on the
queen side all the way with A5 yeah I
was thinking that uh I I wanted to play
the move excuse me there was a trade of
Pawns on no that's me that's no they
traded they did okay sorry to play drug
C8 because I was trying to play A3 and
then suddenly there was a Pawn on D4 so
the computer was updating the moves
takes takes Rook C8
uh
uh A5 there was something to be said for
your space grabbing idea I was going to
play A3 as a response because
you know sometimes this night jumping to
B4 could be annoying and I liked the
pawn on A3 Knight to F1 okay that just
opens up the bishop but I
I've always attributed this maneuver to
carp off because he just played it so
often but of course it's not his
in typical positions like I played this
with black as well sometimes Sicilian D5
E5 Knight E4 I've seen that very often
right exactly but you're getting a
French defense where you shut down your
Bishop Queen C7 by the way does prep
Knight A5 a moment ago if you had played
Knight A5 I would have played Bishop C2
now with the queen on C7 I can't do that
anymore so I have to take Knight A5 is a
serious threat is what I want to say
white can develop the bishop and then
have an in-between rooksy one move
exactly Bishop to D2 and then in case of
Knight A5 just as you were saying
there's the Intermezzo the switch and
zook should we should go to D2 or F4 or
G5 they all look good right I like D2
Bishop to D2 just to bring the Rook to
see what Bishop F4 just so I don't have
to calculate Black's D5
and guess what uh
third alternative
Magnus broke the tie I mean I like D2 I
like that for G5 let's still go to one
of those scores there you go he chose
your move okay but you know for me
mirror when the when they play Bishop G5
H6 Bishop D2 it's like they're saying
the move H6 is a mistake
I don't know if it is a mistake but
that's what white implies right exactly
of course is 8786 and we do have 985 on
the board so Rook C1 that interim
because you'd like to preserve this
bishop you would like to play Bishop C2
only it would cost you a piece in this
exact moment so Rook to C1 Queen B6 and
Bishop C2 Knight C4 huh okay
but uh Bishop C2 Knight C4 I can force
you to take the dark Square Bishop
somehow I want to preserve the light
Square Bishop what has he done
uh he took the Knight on A5 immediately
he said if the Knight comes to C4 meter
May capture the bishop so let me get rid
of the dark swear Bishop now with the
pawn on H6 ideas of E5 Queen B Queen D3
Bishop here
um
shades of the Fabiano game where Fabi
could never get Queen B3 Queen D3 and
Bishop C2 against Magnus is Bishop I
ended up passively on F1 so yeah that
that was uh
on the open file double and C so I don't
think white will manage Bishop C2 here
either yeah exactly uh D5
you want to you want to put your knight
on F5 uh that's that's the ideal uh
square and well Cyrus is saying you're
going to go Knight F5 I'm going to play
Rook to C8 and Bishop f8
and he's done that
pause for just a moment
because here you're supposed to have
your traditional H3 Knight H2 Knight G4
type of ideas
um but we're certainly not there yet are
we maybe just Queen D3
where are we going after Bishop f8
I want to get to G3 later but I will
have to find a good Square for my other
night I'm afraid I'm afraid that that
Bishop is really too good I wanna I
wanna did you see this move I wanted to
take on E7 and put the other Knight to
F5 I did not see Knight takes E5 so a
small tactical operation is trying to
trade pieces but he wants to open up his
Bishop on F7 a bishop on B3 to hit F7 so
day takes e d six and can I just play
Rook d8
uh
[Music]
seven
King takes F7 Queen B3 and takes the
Rook what's the material count by the
way I'm sacrificing a lot of pieces
Knight takes E5 Miro uh engine approved
uh engine approved but then yeah the
path is very narrow because you have to
take the Knight up to D6 Rook d8 white
has to sacrifice the queen take on C7
take the Knight King f8 then take the
rook and it's equal if you find
everything and it goes on and on and on
yes it's very sharp very very sharper he
didn't find Rook d8 by the way after the
move D6 uh Yvonne captured on D6 Queen
takes D6 and this looks promising for
white this is much better for white
because of really the difference this
bishop on B3 now is a monster exactly
Knight H6 is another thread Knight H6 is
on tap 97's on Tab four different
threats exactly but this that whole
operation with Knight takes E5 was
designed
to open up the diagonal for the bishop
and again this Knight on F5 is looking
very very pretty clocks the factors has
extra minute so two and a half against
one and a half
that's not a good thing a bad position
and you're down on time
it's almost a desperate moment
yeah I think Magnus is on his way to win
in his fourth game in a row well he did
something extraordinary earlier in the
grand Chester in Poland where he won 11
games he lost one a couple of draws but
going plus 10 against this field if you
start out with four out of four
he's in great danger of
making a new personal best
that would be terrible
King H7 side steps Knight takes H6 but
okay uh Queen takes and you you
mentioned a while ago if uh in a very
different position a very different
position if I could play Queen G3 no I
was about to allow Maiden one can I
capture because of Rook C1 but no there
is a threat of mate in one and he's on
it is Magnuson right it looks like yeah
looks very good very tempting 96. also a
good option 96 96 might allow 94.
and lucky
okay unlucky but Queen H4 threatening
Queen H4 Knight
I don't want to play 9g8 no but that's
not the way H5 I guess well then we go
Knight D6 and life is good uh it's
almost like I go Queen H4 you have to
take I'll take on F6
exactly that you're oh oh
oh Queen H4 looks like a winner
it looks like a stone cold winner and
the clocks
a Magnus has one minute and 35 seconds
against 49 seconds by the way I'm just
getting an update that uh Duda is much
better against nepo and that's an
important uh important for our standings
of course and
farugia better also also better against
Fabi so two outlets after each round the
standings are changing yeah yeah
shifting Sans is what I want to say but
Queen H4 that's a nasty move Ivan sarich
facing a dual threat of Queen takes H6
down to less than 20 seconds as well and
he doesn't want to play Knight G8
because Knight G8 would allow Knight to
D6 and well the knights H5
ooh this feels really offsides as well
Knight D6
and it almost feels like like like there
should be a tactical solution not that
we need it we're material ahead yeah we
can display Rook D1 and
enjoy our winning position yes we can
yes I also who's kind of tempted by Rook
E3 and rookie one more of a uh yeah with
ideas of E5 and E6
immediately as well and making Luft
with h2h3 is not bad okay Queen D6 yes
Bobby Fischer would take the bishop and
just you know that would be the nail in
the coffin you know from Bobby's point
of view Bobby loved the Bishops so for
him Knight takes B7 uh
for those of us who like strong looking
knights we might just play 51 yes we can
play Rook day one and keep Knight B7 as
an option by the way uh not to be too
critical because I do feel that Magnus
is completely winning but the move h2h3
was kind of soft I wonder what he's
preparing with H3 he definitely has some
idea I really think that E5 would have
been much
better just stopping Queen before the
Queen's out of play yeah white screen on
H4 is a little uncomfortable
and now we see rookie three at A3 yeah
nice in between move yes
yeah otherwise uh we would be losing a
piece did you like the words Intermezzo
or swishin Zug or in between move I say
the first two so
and by the way we do have a breaking
result as vishy came back against gukesh
to win the game Bishop takes F7 and
Magnus
oh that's a really really feminine to
this really pretty uh one now would win
right yep well Rook D6 was played
probably also winning
but I think Rook C1 was a little bit
more convincing it's Queen B7 so yeah
and then 26 it was winning yes
they both have six seconds
um is Michael still winning because
black does have two pieces but they're
ugly but they're ugly pieces right and
we just heard that Magnus is not winning
anymore Ivan played last move with one
second oh twice actually and what about
that 96 was there was a fork
right
E7 going on F4
B7 no he doesn't play he's how do you
resist
oh the queen was hanging apologies yeah
I was about to say get that pawn to E7
the Knight on F5 what's the clock 23
five seconds each
Oh What A Move Knight had to come back
to G7 Queen F5
they're competing repeating once but
then can't you play Rook C8 yes Queen
Queen's Queen C7
and there ah Queen E5 the engine engines
probably laughing on everyone
oh but with no time on the queen
Magnus is so tricky somebody is going to
freeze and he's Queen E5 oh oh no that
loses a piece
and Magnus has done it again
very oh
babe it was the clock that was a crucial
Factor what game has come currently
going on what's happening in Richie's
game
defeated Fabiano
big result big result and nepo won his
game so
it looks like Richie it's certainly
better is it is he winning I think he is
I mean when you when you look at the
very very active white king I would be
stunned if it wasn't winning it should
be yes right D5 here has time for
accurate moves exactly maybe a check
first and then take the pawn on F5
because you're doing it with the tempo
you're threatening mate
shaking his head his heads I feel like
they're making a lot of inaccurate moves
okay it's sometimes the engine is a
detriment I mean it's about the clock
and wait so I
two actually seven yeah
should be winning c66
and then something like
it's is it women
because you can't move your king I
immediately bring my Rook out with the
tempo that is true that uh
but now you're
you're whoa uh oh now it's a no it's an
easy draw right well not easy
King is three
well why did he
okay ah King ba will be one very nice
yeah it wasn't intuitively uh clear oh
no he should have gone King E3 he went
too far he won King E5 okay now Queen
is it even this is unclear
do I keep the
um hmm
we need a table base here is this
winning yes I I I'm quite convinced it's
a it's an easy win
oh he Flex so he flagged
what a game
wow check at the end
I'm I'm pretty sure it was a table base
win but uh we'll we'll have to double
check there again we have a very
eventful uh round with decisive results
on all five games five games right two
rounds in a row with Magnus uh four out
of four Vichy beats Fabby Nepal one
firosha one and Richard one
over to you uh we're fill in the gaps
because uh another eventful uh Blitz
Blitz route uh while pretty much
everything you were watching at the very
end was just you know exchange of not
exchange of blows or even moves it's
exchange of mistakes and it was so hard
to keep up uh final position in Robert
lupulasco white with yeah flag but white
winds by literally every move apart from
Queen City you can just play and black
has to go and he has to leave The Rook I
wanted to quickly show a few moves in go
cash Anon because it was a fascinating
game indeed well
first of all first of all this is one
picturesque position in the center where
it turns out according to the engine you
don't have to take anything I mean you
have to keep the tension and then the
very next slide is here C5 good cache
had to move the bishop away he went for
a brilliant sacrifice in fact takes on
G7 E5 Queen H5 white is brilliant H7 is
hanging and if Anand would play Knight
G6 there is a beautifulest of all
tactics here Queen H6 check that's the
only but sufficient way to continue the
attack Queen H6 check if the queen is
taken it's a Checkmate in two it's
really beautiful this queen H6 I wonder
if gookash had seen it but what he has
missed is F7 F5 and this is the coolest
reply ever after which where she managed
to convert it and the very end the very
end I think good cash overlooked uh well
this was the moment so you guys just
played Rook 8 the E1 pinning the bishop
and then after 94 too many white pieces
hanging so couldn't really do anything
uh very exciting round with all games
decisive so few words to Christian and
Anastasia on the other games
absolutely madness here in Zagreb each
and every game is back and forth
Anastasia which game were you watching I
was checking the game of Fabiano Carana
who doesn't have really great
tournaments so far he came as a
colleague of one of the leaders yes and
then something went really wrong but
this was one of the critical moments
which of the game
um came against alireza firoza and here
I mean it's you can see the opposite
castling and all the pawns are going
forward this is very normal situation
and I was surprised with this move
decision to play G5 here like you closed
the position maybe he could have kept
this city the the position not so
closely instead of G5 you could maybe
try to play Four stop and for the moment
the attack of black and wait for what
will happen maybe he was he didn't like
this idea and then Rook H4 but he could
have played like something like G5 he
has to give up some pawns so exactly yes
because the King on f8 is definitely not
having a great time right compared to
the King on B1 so I was checking this
position back and forth and came to the
conclusion that probably this was his
best chance maybe to play A4 and stop
the counter play of black he didn't do
so and allow allowing alireza to push A4
and then except the queens and after
that they came to descending which you
know step by step alireza managed to win
you know he simply outplayed fabians
and you know for example at this moment
if you play a rookie one and next move
you have to go to catch one things
definitely didn't go the way you wanted
right at this ending so already this
position was worse for Fabi and I must
admit that alireza never gave him any
chance to escape after that he just
simply converted it in a very nice way
absolutely and he dropped below 2 900
maybe after this game he's uh back
around this yes again and I was watching
this game between Jan and uh Christoph
Duda and I have to say this was a
complete mess Jan was doing well up
until about somewhere around this point
where he started losing the advantage
after this move F4 strategical Advantage
because after take only five and Rook to
G6 all of my pieces are finding their
good squares in the position and as we
will see the good trades Bishop takes D1
now I'm having a very nice night coming
to F5 a lot of control over the light
squares and Eurovision D2 is not great
at all this is a better position better
end game for black but once the bishop
gets activated white is getting his own
chances and to be honest still black is
better a pawn up in the position not
enough compensation but some
compensation and then he made a huge
huge mistake at this point
um black that is Yan shustoff Bishop to
E3 H3 this is already a step in the
wrong direction Knight to E6 and now
huge mistake Knight to G5 G2 was the
correct decision it's not easy to play
G2 because after King to E5 you have to
understand that you just simply have to
defend you defend passively this is a
very difficult thing to do especially
with low time on the clock but the pawn
on G2 is going to give you enough
compensation for the position most
likely this position is more or less
equal after Knight to G5 King E5 this is
your simply game over King to E4 I'm
going to take on F6 exchange everything
and I'm going to push my Pawn C6 C7 and
he actually resigned in this position
critical gain for the standings uh by
the way guys and take a look at the
standings who is in the lead you might
ask well it is Magnus Carson in the lead
and he is definitely pushing the pedal
right now 15 points I told you very
important crucial Victory from a losing
position 14 and a half and Fabiano
unfortunately as you were mentioning is
not having the greatest of days in a
blitz but uh around four or round five I
don't think I lost count is coming up
shortly we will go on a short commercial
break and we'll be back soon don't go
anywhere
[Music]
welcome to grantchester finally you are
here you are the youngest participant
and it's your first time are you looking
forward for this event yeah
one of the most prestigious events
inches and making my debuts really
special for sure yeah for sure and also
it's special for your fans and I was
wondering since which age do you
remember actually about the existence of
grantchester when did you start to
follow the events of grantchester do you
remember any specific event
um
I think I started like
a few years back I don't remember
exactly but uh yeah I do follow all the
all the events and
especially since like granchester has
like most of the top 10 players so many
strong players it's it's of course a
nice event to follow and
um I mean especially in Zagreb there was
a very nice event which Magnus dominated
in 2019 that remember that event I
remember quite quite well yeah that's
great and also this event is very
special also because uh vishana
displayed here right and you're going to
play together in the same tournament uh
have it ever happened before and what
are you thinking about it the fact that
you played together with vision
yeah of course we've interacted a lot
we've trained together we've played some
training games but uh this is going to
be my first time in a tournament game
actually and yeah I can't be more
excited for it yes I mean three games
with me yeah where you're dreaming about
it before I mean at the start I couldn't
even dream about it but
but yeah I like
hey I've always wanted to play play him
in a tournament game and
I have an opportunity here and this is
there's going to be like
um a lot of fun and uh
yeah hopefully we'll play some very nice
games yeah we hope so too for sure and I
was also wondering what was your
preparation the preparational routine
over this years I know that you were not
using for some favorite computers I mean
how new technologies affected your
preparation and do you use it now right
now
yeah till the pandemic started I have I
wasn't really working with computers but
after that I'm
working with computers regularly
I mostly use them for openings and like
I mean preparation for this for this
tournament it's been just a
some openings and puzzles and Playing
Games
Etc yeah and my last question you know
in this event and many others from the
young age you have to play against
really strong upon it's higher rated and
you know many kids many young players
they have this fear to play with high
rated stronger opponents how do you
fight with those fears I mean what what
do you tell to yourself I mean how do
you go through all this
I guess I'm I'm experienced and if not
to like fear stronger opponents I mean I
I used to do that when I was very young
but
I guess I've gotten used to it now what
how do you get this self-confidence
I guess once you start beating opponents
beating uh higher returns it's uh
it's just uh I guess it's just
experience yeah that's great I mean just
start beating them and you feel much
better and more confident yes so thank
you so much and very appreciate your
answer sent all the best of luck in your
first GCT event yeah thank you
[Music]
hello hello and welcome back our
standings after very eventful Blitz four
rounds of Blitz right Magnus is
Unstoppable he won another game and he's
four in a row uh in the second place
yeah
and look at those guys there are two
points in point and a half ahead of
third place which is Fabiano caruano
exactly and our pairings for this fifth
round coming up very exciting on board
one Anand against Carlson and between
those two they have 10 World
Championships
uh classical and and there that will be
our Marquee matchup but board two
ferrugia versus gupcash and we'll be our
Rebecca absolutely and the local escrow
they're playing Carolina Duda faced in
Rapport and sarich against Nepal Mission
very unlucky Ivan sarich Napa will be
looking to win with the black pieces and
our producers were kind of impressed by
the body language of the players between
uh oops I apologize for that but there's
going to be a special coming up uh we
saw this game between Magnus and Yvonne
sarich where the point was like a hot
potato marrow that was getting passed
around a great deal and maybe oh here it
is here's comes the the body language
forget about the moves for just a second
just look at the bodies
I like the
and my
pieces that he's
an Agnes let out he was holding his
breath that look Miro how many times did
the victory get tossed back and forth in
that uh well I've lost count I know I
know sarich was winning on two occasions
for sure right and you can only imagine
how many times it went from Magnus being
winning to equal so that was that was
really back and forth his age and the
point there was it was really seconds
they were both playing on the increments
and it was uh well topsy-turvy all the
way as we get ready for this round five
pairings I want to say Vichy Anand
you know okay started incredibly well
and then he kind of drifted a little bit
but uh thus far I mean does she you know
he just beat gukash uh well earlier and
before he beat Fabi and he beat Bobby
which goes to show
on any given moment uh that she can
outdo the very best now he will be up
against the very best against Magnus and
I have to say the last few years it's
almost been a kind of a hex that Magnus
has over but she he needed to win Magnus
needed to beat him in the Rapids and he
did yes and then there was this
wonderful game in The Grand in the
global chess League that was just played
in Dubai where Magnus probably won the
end game of his life promo under
promoted to promote it oh that was just
the stalemates it was gorgeous as uh the
players get ready for round five but if
fun the player who is having a tough day
today is Fabiano he just lost two games
in a row oops and yeah it's gonna be
tough to come back my pick dude uh I
mean he's getting good positions he had
a good position with Magnus he had a
good position with Napa but he's not
getting the results uh sometimes it just
happens that way Miro uh you get the
good positions but you don't get the
results you get the bad positions but
then you get the results uh well you get
entertaining positions and win them and
then your record Rapport who has won two
games in a row in a very very you know
funky fashion I want to say oh really
okay uh the games are underway let's
jump to the game of Vichy versus a
Magnus as uh one E2 E4 uh this year his
whole life has been an E4 player and
guess what we've got it we've got a Caro
with
very surprised that Bishi went for this
ending because I I've never felt
uncomfortable as black in this ending I
want to say it's it's been popular
recently whoa
G5 okay
uh that is some kind of very very
special prep because you you want to
play G4 and you want to play Bishop H6 I
think
that part is a little bit obvious but
wow G4 yeah he's he's going for his
setup all the rules
three well the rule well your your king
is on B1 but Bishop D3 that's a very
strange move to my mind because it it
it's like a magnet it's inviting Knight
D7 95 which is where I want to go why
would you put your Bishop In Harm's Way
Miro could you share any insights about
something G5 yeah well sorry to you know
to disappoint you but all known G5 is
the best move confirm engine confirmed
the G4 is the rare move but still exists
and then the the position we have is
already fresh and obviously equal
according to the machine
um I'm kind of partial to Black actually
uh you just took the two Bishops he
played Knight takes D3 C takes d3s
followed up with Bishop E6 if I get to
play Bishop takes C4
this you know some weak squares in
White's Camp so you might have to move
your knight even if we don't get to play
Bishop C4 the pawn on D3 is a backward
pawn and we have two Bishops so I think
yeah from an opening perspective I think
black uh will feel like he's Magnus will
feel pretty good King E2 by the way on
the board uh just uh defending D3
sidestepping issues that might occur on
the D file
on the board Bishop to G7 probably what
you were saying about the two Bishops
yeah we'll see probably Bishop E3 right
Bishop E3 eyeballing the a pawn just
making it that much more that's still
Castle short yes
um
I'm a little bit partial to H5 and
grabbing more space over there unless
the move Knight A5 is a is a disrupter
that could be quite unpleasant right
so maybe black can still prepare for
Knight A5 okay how would we do that well
it's played 97 I don't know exactly why
that would stop Knight A5
um
I'm not sure I'm threatening to take
this Pawn by the way maybe I can I can
come along because click on A7 your
Bishop should be trapped
but you know when you're playing against
somebody who you just know will take the
bond it's yeah you you double check six
nights to 16 B7 take the Rook
and take on B6 I get three points I took
A7 C6 and B6 yeah so it's kind of funny
okay Rook on A1 it's a C1 so at a
certain moment you might oh he'd play F5
I was about to say at a certain moment
you might start to play Bishop takes C4
followed by Knight E5 but he did play F5
makes sense he has two Bishops here
wants to open up the diagonals well
again uh if I'm in White Shoes the the
move that definitely has my attention is
knight uh A5 I suppose the idea behind
Rook C1 is you might go for a minority
attack based on B4 and B5 now that
you've supported your knight but F5 uh
should we take on a five or not touch it
I don't know I don't know uh
I leave it for the moment I kind of
leave it up for well I took
commentator's curse the moment I took is
stand 94 by the way that she was looking
at Knight D6
I see you I see your uh fork and I'll
get out of it castles short and first
impressions are
black is looking good Black's looking
good two two Bishops and uh the King on
E2 right now the King on E2 is not in
any real danger but uh well it's still
in the center it's going to Black is
going to start to
open up the the files now here was a
question would you take with a pawn
okay do you think so well
well yeah right exactly taking with the
pawn is counter-intuitive it's something
that you don't want to do until you
start to see well if I ever get to play
f54 that King could be in the center
okay I might lose the pawn on B7 but
takes on
and Magnus is thinking about it thank
you all three options are very good
takes Bishop takes and phone takes
once again now that you've had a chance
to reflect would you no he took with the
bishop I was about to try to do my Jedi
mind trick on you there get you to take
with the pawn uh Bishop takes a F6 so
Knight A5 still looking good right we've
been tapping the table for so long uh
the problem
the problem I think with Knight A5 is
now Black's just in time to play
conveniently Rook d8 with a Tempo uh
threatening Bishop D3 check
and if you guard that pawn then Rook B7
Rook D7 it allows Rook D3 Bishop D3 yeah
Bishop D3 why not Rook D3 that's also an
option right
true that sorry uh
whenever I see an opportunity to gain a
Tempo I I look at it first so I was
looking at the checks first but you're
right Rook takes D3 definitely uh it's a
playable move because you probably can't
play Rook C6
he's done it as you've suggested Rook
takes a D3 Rook take C6 what did you
want to say Nasi I feel like there
should be a tactic after six but it's
too early to discover what it might be
uh probably as simple as Rook B3 uh just
hitting the pawn and ideas of a check on
the second rank white king is actually
not that great on E2 it looked like
Vichy was reaching for his Knight to
bring his Knight back into civilization
Knight to C5 but there is this move Rook
A3 and those Bishops are controlling uh
but an array of brackets that Rook on A8
it's very passive is it time to play A5
oh wait I like A5 it does a lot right it
suddenly this Rook on A8 that is
inactive okay
you have to uh look at the ramifications
of B5 but I think A5
or B8 okay it's similar idea just
bringing the rook in the game but do I
have Knight D7 now for since I'm
exchanges
first of all the answer was yes I I
thought that Knight D7 was actually a
very good move in order to get rid of
this dark Square Bishop but Rook C4
something to be said for it as well I
mean it's not like 97 and
checks you've got a convenient way of
handling a check the king
microsys is slightly down on the clock
just slightly
and 30 34 Magnus
or for Anand 97 again
sure looks attractive
is she thinking maybe Knight A6
of the Pawn on A4 is still hanging sorry
I was I was going Pond hunting there
with Knight A6 and Rook C6 and Bishop A7
but the pong on A4 is still hanging
clock's a factor
they have more than one minute but this
is the thing this is like it's already a
20 second thing and uh vichys reaching
for his night I think he wants to play
Knight to D7 the problem here is there's
too many moves and that's not a good
thing when you're playing a Blitz game
sometimes you want just a very narrow
path check King E1 again
but he manages to exchange oh is there
Rook takes B4 here
it takes what oh group before Bishop set
three oh excuse me I don't know if it
works
whoa Bishop to E6
idea of Rook takes Rook takes
if Knight p8 just Bishop C4 okay
so Rook C6
Rook takes B4 I think
I'm pausing because it certainly is that
it is getting tricky but I'm pausing
because Rook F4 is also kind of
attractive he's gone for Rook C6 but
he's allowed this uh Rook takes B4 and
that Bishop on F6 is doing a great job
at defending the king Rook takes A7 that
she's saying do your worst
whoa oh there's a blunder miro's giving
me a hint Bishop D4 is winning here for
black he's spotted it of course
played it in just three seconds exactly
because you want to play Rook check but
Bishop D4 you have Rook C1 so if you can
get rid of the bishop Bishop to D4
and now Rook takes G2 and suddenly
picking up all the pawns yes exactly
it's a harvest suddenly this Pawn this
pawn and for the moment
the black king is really safe again I I
mentioned it at the start of the round
that Magnus somehow has a hex a voodoo
uh thing going and there we go Magnus
wins fifth game in a row four seconds
and Vichy said I've seen enough
let's jump to the game of farugia
board one board one and he's up against
the 17 year old Phenom from India kukesh
structure more active pieces yeah
it's funny
um
in the classical jargon it was this idea
that white has a protected past Pawn and
we used to think highly of these pawns
on D5
in modern chess I've noticed that uh
less and less players are saying uh that
it's such a great advantage that the
pawns can be blockaded by the way Richie
he just defeated
my pick I'm telling you uh Jan is
getting great positions just not the
results
kukash
in tournaments like this it's the result
that matters exactly exactly
so they're down to less than 15 seconds
both
um can white break through somehow
or does black have a fortress
book C2 so now I can play okay five I'm
not sure uh five so now Queen B5 allowed
pawn exchange but this is looking good
for firosha one second he just made it
either for three seconds
so he was down to one they again you get
a two second uh
Queen B7 now or queen D7 Queen D7
threatening made on H7 you have to go
Queen G8
and they went in tactics F6 is hanging
yeah threatening mate on G5 and
handshake
could have been five for five what do we
have remaining we have nothing let's
jump to it and wait a minute sorry
checks for peace for a pawn uh two
connected passers
uh but this last move Look C5 he's ready
to meet uh F3 with Bishop G3 so G4 are
you fast enough well that's the question
she forged Shaq and Rook
Rook A4 sneaky okay rookie four
but the jacket upon is kind of
Unstoppable but we do have we do have
Bishop whoa that is a challenging move
and A4 and he's he's relying upon his
oops he's relying upon his Bishop to
okay but hold on
King A5 he's first is it equal oh yes we
both promote and white has Pawn on C2
but it's black to move so
okay this should be a draw check on B1
should be enough uh yeah
well it's I wouldn't say a drawing Blitz
exactly 11 seconds 11 seconds oh yeah
check check yeah that's just the
familiar uh Checkmate before yeah and
the players have agreed to a draw any
other game remembering probably let's
jump
Constantine four seconds hold on that's
a past Pawn on the B2 one square from
Coronation
and Bobby says give me another queen
and there's a mate on H1
yes
wow we had almost all decisive results
again only one draw
who drew that was the one we just saw
the the draw but uh well Magnus has
Unstoppable Magnus is looking at just
Regal as he's carving his way through
the field with five out of five Magnus
cementing as lead the farugia close four
out of five nepo made a draw in a
position he was a bishop down uh Miro uh
fill in the gaps
what happened
wow and you tell me I mean a lot of lot
of stuff uh Ricker report a man who I've
mentioned right before the start of this
round right he has won yet another game
this time against Yankton and what a
game that was
in defense once again I think it was
played against right in round one and
didn't go as planned but this time it
worked marvelous
uh right I guess this is a very
difficult position for this line and
then F4 is something you shouldn't be
doing okay it's very ambitious you know
block the center but then Richard comes
up with A5 A3 takes takes and B5 and
then it's a pawn sacrifice but if you
capture it just look at like white
randomly shuffled his pieces over the
board and black has more than sufficient
compensation of the queen B6 so Duda
continued in a very ambitious fashion
how you know strangle yeah I will not
let you play but rapper keeps finding
squares for his pieces and especially
after this Rook A4 you start to
understand yeah Black's gonna double
will play G6 Bishop G7 that's what
happened in the game eventually and yeah
somewhere around this point it's already
evident that it's black who is playing
for a win and then we are getting to
this moment when they both were on like
very short on time like maybe 10 seconds
and they've exchanged a couple of
blunders here F5 G takes G takes and
then e takes was Stronger but how would
you know E5 and then white had a move to
kind of come back into the game with
Rook G1 once again not an easy move to
spot right but you are pinning blacks
pieces and then you say black captures
on D4 then you do something along the
lines of King H1 and then all of a
sudden it's you who's attacking and
instead to the captured the pawn on E5
and this happens to be a crucial mistake
because now Knight to G4 and if you take
the Knight it's Knight to F4 winning the
queen and after Knight G4 Queen B3 Rook
C2 just wait you take back and you lose
the queen anyway so nice nice game by
Rishi who is
uh I don't remember if he won more but
certainly three out of three right uh
right in Naples game nepo's game who's
also you know I mean if I would tell you
that it started like this an absolutely
you know symmetrical dry end game would
you would you imagine that something
like we've witnessed happened yeah okay
there was a very very top-sitter every
game uh yeah let's ask Christian maybe
he has found something in those other
games that were not covered
well you guys did cover at the end of
that game of Ali Reza but Anastasia I
will let you go first because you had
quite an important game that game
between lupulasco who is definitely
struggling in this event and Fabiano who
just lost
get back with a victory
you're absolutely right of course Fabi
after losing a couple of games today he
really needed some luck and he got it
today because lopolisco was absolutely
outplaying him look at this position
which is on the board after the opening
you can see that fabulate with two
weaknesses on B6 and D6 and the position
really looked not so great
um actually uh Constantine could have
played something like D5 a very very
interesting move opening his Bishop also
and whatever you take on D5 beautiful
move you know whatever you take you
always stand up in the in the worst
position I will not go into details what
I want to say that okay all the way he
was better and like he grabbed the pawn
on D6 and let's say white is doing
really good but then they came to the
point when both of them had like 5
seconds on the clock and it was all
about time and who is playing faster and
five it turned out to be a better player
in please and I just want to show one
interesting moment when things seem to
be better for Fabiano he played this
move Rook C4 and tried to find now the
move forward
you see it second time in this game D5
and black is losing immediately the Rope
yes that's awesome yeah that's a win so
again constantly palesco had really
great chance and but black is on the
farthest side right now it's very
similar to what happened in the rapid
portion it was exactly the same Fabiano
had a losing position then it was a draw
and then unfortunately localesco in the
last few seconds it's all about those
things
absolutely let's take a look at what
happened in that game that you guys
caught at the end of between alireza and
gookish once again a very important game
because Ali Reza this guy is warmed up
right now four out of five that's a very
significant result and let's take a look
what happened they play the English e35
and this is kind of a concession already
I'm giving black the center I'm giving
black potentially the advantage out of
the opening but at the same time once
you play the move E5 you also weaken
some light squares in the center
specifically that square D5 and as white
I'm going to try to take advantage of
that we see Queen to beat recently
defining the control over D5 and D3 G3
getting the bishop on the long diagonal
all about this uh Square D5 and by the
way I'm not saying that for no reason as
you will see in just a second it was the
whole game all about that square D5
it's a completely positional game yes
Bishop to F5 this was the critical
moment F4 white is attacking and trying
to open up the center and the King side
black is trying to do something and get
more space on the queen side as we see
A5 take take Knight to E4 Knight to F6
and after the move Rook to d8 E4 this is
the prediction it's like a completely
cemented where is he trying to get the
bishop on D5 on D5 exactly but right now
this move Bishop to G7 is just simply
two passing what he had to do alireza at
this point is to understand that
it is now black who is attacking on the
king side it doesn't sound like the
correct idea but as you can see after
Bishop to G5 and this is not an easy
move to make because right now the
bishop B2 doesn't have a counterpart on
the long diagonal so this looks visually
dangerous but what you can do with Tempo
Queen to E2 Bishop to H3 that's another
Tempo on The Rook you have to defend
against that and then
I see where your mind is no Rook D4 is
very nice but I'm going to just simply
cage yes I'm not going to capture it I'm
going to cage it with a move a bishop to
a D5 so what you want to do actually is
go King to H7 followed by Rook to f8 and
then F5 you're the one attacking on the
king side you have the two Bishops on G5
and H3 and despite the fact that that
Bishop is going to be very beautiful on
D5 it doesn't have a Target after Rook
to f8 F5 beautiful Bishop on D5
unfortunately my Bishop's close to your
king are very very dangerous and perhaps
decisive he missed that opportunity went
into a very passive approach with Bishop
to G7 and unfortunately I have to say at
this point it is only white that's
playing for a victory because if you do
take on D5 you're creating a past Pawn
for white you're also creating a
weakness the pawn on C5 which alireza as
you guys saw in those last few moments
took full advantage of important victory
for Ali Raza and right now he's keeping
close uh to a Magnus in fact let's take
a look at the standings perhaps if we do
have them we know that Magnus is leading
the tournament
but we're actually going to go back to
St Louis and we're going to show the
standings from there guys back to you
thank you Anastasia thank you Christian
in fact let's take a look at before we
came in today the rapid chess results
let's remind everybody what the
situation was I mean right after the
time for first after three days of Rapid
there was a tie for first
and Publishing with Magnus clearly and
third and now let's see what's happening
today after five rounds of Blitz Magnus
is in clear first thing so the top three
are still the same players that's true
but they've changed the order definitely
so now Magnus is in the lead and
neposing the second and Fab is in third
and let's take a look at the upcoming uh
pairings for round six and two leaders
wow against Nepal that's a marquee
matchup right there if ever saw one the
rapper will be playing
uh our backup as we're gonna go on a
short commercial break and we'll see you
on the other side for round six of the
Blitz
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Croatia you were here in
2021 what kind of memories do you have
from that times
um yeah I think it was mostly good
memories I mean my tournament was
so so I finished a short fourth I think
or fifth within the punji if memory
serves well but I mean in that very
tournament I want two games I mean beats
games against casparov it was of course
A very huge thing for me back then and
yeah I mean you know I played good games
about games but in general I was very
like happy with my performance uh here
in the group so um yeah I'm looking
forward you know repeating it yeah I
mean about the game but it's gaining
better uh you know
that's important yes and actually now
that the last time I saw you was in
Poland and this dramatic last round you
know when you played against Magnus and
like I was just wondering how did you
feel after that event and let's see what
happened after did you still analyze
this game or you just decided to forget
about it and just enjoy the second place
like what were your feelings right after
that
yeah I was quite unhappy to be honest
back then because usually you know when
you are a professional chess player that
is usually about negative like feedback
because when you win you win because
you're yourself 20 euros and especially
when you feel you could you know do
better
and or make some you know unfoldsful
errors then um yeah it can get very
negative and in my case it was like
purely I mean second place didn't make
me happy though because I was like
leading in most of the tournaments
but um yeah but subjectively saying I
guess uh it was quite good performance
by by me and I'm looking to repeat it
the Lewis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as high
profile tournaments that attract the
world's best players become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischesclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our live
coverage it's been a very very eventful
five rounds of Blitz as we get ready for
round six Magnus Carlson has been on a
tear he's won every single game but
not doing very bad at all three out of
five yeah and he's climbing up the ranks
there is you see the rapid scores and
you see with the current scores here
just add that's what they've won in the
blitz all right Magnus still leading the
tournament but firusha and Richard after
winning a couple of games in a row
they're sharing fourth now absolutely
and here's what's coming up as far is
the pairings for round six well all
important Magnus versus nepo game and
the Vichy versus faruga game that too is
a looking really good Miro jump in on
the on the blitz thus far
uh while I'm impressed with report as
well because he did the math he has done
as good as ferrugia with four out of
five and recalling that he has lost in
the first round today that means four in
a row right yeah I'm I'm forcefully
reminded of the comment by a chief
Arbiter Hans kamak
um
Bobby Fischer won the U.S Championship
with a perfect score 11 out of 11. and
Hans
congratulated the second place uh
player Larry Evans for winning the
tournament congratulations Larry Evans
for winning the tournament and
congratulations Bobby Fisher for winning
the exhibition
and it feels like Magnus is performing
the exhibition as he just uh at the
lower right uh of your screen shook the
hand of nepo and nepos preparing now
you're sitting there in nepo shoes and
you're black against Magnus who's been
on a tear even if Magnus has had bad
positions he's won them
what is nepo thinking like how do I stop
this guy right or maybe he's thinking
how do I survive this game right right
okay he's ready to play the Russian
defense in case of E4 so here comes D4
and what are we going to do against the
Catalan because that's coming up I want
to point out and I post tattoo on all
over his arm yes
that that's a new one for me too right
or where is it there we are yes we have
another catalog so a Catalan uh right
now we haven't yes it's open Catalan
with D5 takes C4 Knight C3 right away
and pawn sacrifice
this line of the Catalan I want to say
uh for me Boris girlfriend has always
been a player who's been very willing to
sacrifice these pawns Rook B8
prepping B5
Queen E2 so E4 is actually not the most
common movie E3 was more more
information yeah
and Rook D1 now here because our Pawn is
actually nicely on C4 you're often
attracted to the move Knight to B4 so
that you can end up occupying the D3
square but uh I think White's prepared
with Knight E1 well he's done it 91 or
95. Knight E1 that's defend D3 but 95 I
was ready I was ready to play Knight D7
in case and 91 on the board
okay isn't this the no C5 dc5 Queen C7
walking Chevy Bishop F4 I do have E5 I
really want to play C5 uh and
it has to be a little bit patient here
before they can play C5 but help me out
what am I missing once again C5 I take
Queen C7 Bishop oh you have E5 that was
my idea yes I think five immediate
leadership F4
ah that helps so Bishop B7
uh wait a minute
Spidey senses
yeah sorry Knight takes B5 Bishop takes
E4 I think is good enough
okay uh this move does finally uh
prepare the movie C5 so before now looks
logical he played eight three three six
oh maybe now he can take on B5
it's logical why not
and he's done it and then Nepal
immediately looked at the sun like wait
a minute have I messed things up and
Miro has he messed things up uh well let
me see Magnus I mean uh Magnus just
grabbed the B5 pawn and
well
now computer is not impressed says A7 A6
and then if Knight goes back you can
take on D4
simple chess right so it has something
like A6 D5 and
and you know it's a lot of long-winded
variation thereafter but A6 and Nepal
just kind of stopped after Knight B5 and
it was like nepo seemed to suggest that
oh wait a minute my preparation
everything went South
or maybe he was surprised that white can
take on B5 because in the variation
mirror suggested uh if black grabs the
D4 Pawn shouldn't that be great for
Black by the way he did not play Asics
he played Bishop A6 and uh
Magnus saw no reason why he had to
retreat his Knight he played A4 sorry
Magnus will be happy if Nepal exchanges
the the for the night well he's really
dreaming is magnus's dreaming if he
could get in the move Queen takes C4
he's a really really happy camper that
would probably just be winning in fact
Bishop F4 uh threatening the pawn on C7
forced obliged black to capture on B5
and now that really takes the sting out
of B93 Knight B3 is always going to be
met by Rook A7 so here it just feels
like white is per Choice how do I how do
I really
Knight C2
by the way we're just uh being told that
farugia is really winning nicely against
Vichy uh Knight C2 you couldn't take on
B2 The Rook had to defend the night on
A5
the idea was to play Knight A3 Knight
takes E4 Queen B8 so that Knight exactly
Rook takes B2 on tap
how do we continue I like White's
position but you need the accurate moves
he would think something like Rook A4
because the idea is Rook B2 is not on
Tab yet what's her next move well I
wanted to sidestep things like Knight B3
so that I could play Bishop to D2 and
Bishop to C3 that way I cover the pawn
but I I don't want the Knight to come
with a Tempo so if I could go Rooks Rook
A4 and Rook C4 I'm happy
he's still thinking
sorry
I'm sitting there looking for the
movement I can't figure it out also like
maybe D5 try to start opening things up
full pair of fish we do indeed
nicely I guess
one in a row
I'm happy with both well I I was trying
to borrow a page from um nepo right a
one one win in a row would be nice takes
and E5 very uh
I I've seen this tactic happen so often
that you play D5 not with the idea of
recapturing when the pawn can easily be
blocked but blockaded but to play E5 and
force the Knight to move Knight to E4
not backing down that was probably the
only good move yeah you don't want to
allow whites two Bishops to shine with a
move like Bishop takes D5 but Knight E4
okay Bishop takes and queen takes E4
it's nice
there's also some Queen G4 Knight D4
Knight F5 ideas now because Knight D4
comes with a Tempo if you take Rook B2
Queen G4 another Tempo because Knight on
A5 is still hanging
yep and then you've got Knight F5
but I am sacrificing a lot of fun stuff
yeah but they're not your Pawns
uh I like it uh Bishop T I mean he went
for
the combination of your idea but it
included Bishop E4 oh Knight F2 was
hanging with a Tempo and queen's under
attack yes exactly when your queen goes
to G4 there is a knight takes F2 Tempo
so Knight to D4 Rook takes Queen to G4
the Knight is hanging the Knight goes to
B3 the Knight goes to F5 yep there's
also some 196 once the night leaves so
hello yeah
yeah that's a nice Point too very sharp
but it looks like nepo is the one on the
back foot here because this move Knight
F5 is very disturbing
Rook is under attack and The Rook has to
keep an eye on the ape Pawn A5 Knight
sacrifice The Exchange Play Bishop C5
just try to get rid of that Knight give
up the exchange and say it's all yours
because after rugby two queen G4 it
might just be winning for it it looks
terrible actually
it looks terrible uh
there's H5 after Queen G4
that's an annoying in between move so
say it again Queen G4 and H5
and if I take it well now neither five
is not that dangerous
still still looks good though right I
understand what you mean it's not
threatening made I can also have G6 with
a Tempo so
fair fair
nepo on the clock uh under a minute
under a minute yes but this is a very
critical moment he needs to see that he
has H5 otherwise he can't go for Rook B2
exactly rugby two queen G4 H5
that really yeah that move H5 really is
annoying it throws us off of our mojo
and he did play Knight B3 so he is
inviting Knight C6 as well uh
Knight C6 96 Queen E8 Queen takes C4
yes because if you play Rook C5 I have
check and then take the Knight
very good for white a rugby six and by
the way grabbing another Pawn is a Pawn
on A7 that just got lopped off so even
though I just took two pawns material
it's equal
really at the moment yes okay uh
shocking it just feels like white the
nuded black queen takes e-force on tap
Rook takes c7s on top potential of East
E6 and nepo is running out of time as
well I mean something we don't say often
no we don't Queen E6 inviting
Queen takes E4 not interested said
Magnus I've got this beautiful past pawn
and I've got Rook D6
I think Rook D6 is the dream move
yeah he exchanged the Queens very
quickly because it's just a winning end
game and he has no risk as well
to result game for sure H4 H5
it's it's playing a role it is stopping
the B Farm Pawn from from from
running up the board but on the other
hand the Knight is not stable so it
easily dislodged
Rook to D6 and again just tell me about
the clock times so Magnus still has more
than one minute more than a minute okay
it's just 21 seconds because we have
seen Magnus go down to seconds on his
clock as we saw against Yvonne saritch
by the way the last move Bishop E3
making it to sooji against the Knight a
domination
it's a Japanese expression from the game
of Go when you dominate the piece and in
this case the bishop dominates the
Knight
but this is nice Magnus is saying you
can keep the
the the double pawns on the e-file they
give me this H Bond then I'll have a
passer and magnuses
Russia has
um is not winning anymore
thank you and you sorry you were saying
that uh Anand escaped and uh against
Borussia okay Rook to be no no Rook no
Rook to B5 six seconds 40 seconds for
Magnus
technically win an end game but time to
get rid of that night right Rook check
and get rid of you mean win it well yeah
I was going to say Rook check and Rook
B5 to just to force that Knight away
G4
he's changing
the bishop for the night
I think actually in Blitz it makes sense
because at night
It's Tricky there's Knight F3 coming in
just to break uh break the bad news for
vichy's fans vishy lost yeah
he was fine but oh he blundered in one
move
and uh we're we're being told that
Richard Rapport who had been on a little
bit of a tear
lost to Evon sarich who has not had oh
uh B5 what what the heck happened
Magnus nipple playing very quickly but
now the g-pawn is Unstoppable there is a
threat of Rook check well there's a
Checkmate next Mo Brook F6 Rook F6 made
in one Magnus six out of six let's just
quickly go to Fabi before we sing
magnus's praises
Duda
um
I've been waiting but it was like that
for a long time whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
a blunder blunder alert played with one
second on the clock uh dude a blundered
an exchange now Fab is up in exchange oh
my word
so what happens when you have one second
yeah I didn't know that time travel
makes fools of us all would say this is
still possible to hold but very
difficult of course
would be maybe easier for Duda if he had
a bishop in the night right
okay but he is trying to set his night
up on G5 the Knight on G5 does a great
job at Hope protecting E6 and ideas that
you've even Knight h
the other night is too
yes
okay King H6 I don't see how to yet
Knight H3
so the king can always
Waltz to G5
as he's done
and Knight F5 check no okay the Knight
came back to life big time and you're oh
he didn't take it so he's encouraging
the check players under five seconds
students just playing so
slowly doesn't mind that he has only two
seconds on the clock and finally he
takes and bringing his Knight back to G5
to E4 I would suspect
is this a draw well it feels like it's
like he's winning
oh excuse me yeah because there goes the
pawn
now it should definitely be a draw for
sure with the Knight two Palms
yeah
don't go King E5 that would be or King
F4 E5 that's how Anan lost against
firosha he blundered four
or one of those tricky nights
who's playing for a win Fabi right I
guess fabby's still playing for a win
but I think he's going to give up uh his
efforts shortly as the night will return
to Chief no
commentators curse I thought that I
you turn to G5 but since white kid
activated the king I don't even say the
ideas to win
I guess if Black blanders age five fun
then I would have ideas and he may have
just done that what is six yeah he just
blundered his h-bond it's like hilarious
uh just as you were saying that and he
and another Pawn now White's winning oh
my goodness
telling me and now it's a dragon I don't
know why but table base was saying E2
was a draw
E2
instead of night night yeah
very difficult to play this kind of end
game accurately with four seconds on the
clock and now you have to play King at
two Knight E3 check Knight E3 check what
has he done
five oh
Fatty's very lucky he didn't lose the
game oh Queen G3 I mean dude is lucky
but Bobby didn't play King F2 both both
players are very very excited and very
happy about the draw marrow
fill in the gaps there as we just
witnessed Magnus when his sixth game on
the trot
what have we missed well yeah so
honestly for this last game I'm really
happy it was a draw because there was so
many mistakes that inevitably one would
be heartbroken right in this game uh
right so we don't have that much time so
just two highlights from two games and
this time one will be just a terrible
mistake that Richard dropper made
against Ivan sarage he was better at
some point we are tuning in at the
position where he probably has to accept
that okay the advantage has gone and
just played Bishop C3 he went Bishop B6
perhaps being on seconds so this pin
missed that off the check you would
think you attack The Rook but then
Bishop B6 attacks yorub so it was just a
terrible blunder and then a touch of
greatness from goo cash who played
rather one-sided game against lopulesku
and that was like you know the very
funny final moment Queen G5 and at least
the album swapping the queens and played
the Berlin game no such luck for you sir
Rook takes Queen takes Jack and the
check mid on H7 so well very nice tactic
and good cash wins a very convincing
game against the police
nice thank you Miro uh uh let's jump to
Zagreb and get a review from the playing
Hall
a lot of ups and downs this is what
Bliss chess is all about and this is
exactly what happened in this game
between Fabiano and Duda you guys caught
the end of it I'll show the critical
moments that led to that type of
position at this point uh it seemed like
white is just having the typical opening
slight Advantage but unfortunately he uh
played a very bad move Fabiano that is
he played the move C5 that just simply
gives away too many squares specifically
the D5 Square which immediately got
taken away uh by Duda and to be honest
after that Duda played a marvelous
strategical Masterpiece took the pawn
and got into this position it seemed
like conversion is within his grasp but
unfortunately for him at this point he
started straying away what he had to do
was Knight to BC's control at the entry
Square D7 square but also Tie The Rook
to the defense of the square A4 because
if you do move the Rook anywhere around
I'm going to go A4 myself kick the
bishop away from B3 and let's go to be
all she wrote so Knight to B6 a critical
moment he did not play that he allowed
the root to get active which obviously
is not the optimal thing that you can do
still black is a pawner but
unfortunately the material is getting
limited and I have to say this is when
white is starting to have ideas and this
was uh the big big Miss Knight to D4 to
be honest this is a fair result Duda was
winning for the majority of the game
missed this move Knight to D4 even after
that it was more or less equal
unfortunately for him he got into a
losing position once again this is Blitz
you covered the the end of the game when
Anan simply blundered the roof but
actually starting from the beginning it
was one I think that here we are in this
game there was a moment that he
I think also blundered
yeah I want to show it like here you put
Queen D2 I think missing the move Rook
P5 I mean hard to believe that he really
sacrificed this two pieces for The Rook
uh and after Queen C4 ended up in the
worst position but you know later on he
managed to come back to the game because
Larissa decided to change the roofs at
this moment which was I think uh on
favor of white and not good quite good
chances later on and he was pushing the
pawns and he managed even to get to his
second Pawn on D6 so it was to pass Pawn
I mean the position became tricky and
unclear so it's decent for a while yeah
exactly so I think the position was
pretty pretty good for him until certain
point and of course this last blow like
he missed his Rook simply the fork at
the very end let me show it again uh he
just put in places oh my goodness yes
seven I think yes slightly better
position
it just shows that you that the players
are getting tired already and it's name
it's already day foreign
let's take a look at the standings after
round six here in Zagreb of Blitz of
course we have Magnus Carlson who is
cannot stop winning I mean he's he won
absolutely every single game up to this
point uh Jan two points behind he
started off one point behind the leaders
right now is two points ahead Fabiano 14
and a half Ali Reza piling up some
victories 14 points which report 13 and
all the way down to Constantinople
struggling only three points in this
event an amazing tournament after this
point still three rounds left in today's
battles we're going to go on a short
commercial break and we'll be back
shortly with round seven stay with us
[Music]
finally you are here you are the
youngest participant and it's your first
time are you looking forward for this
event yeah
granchester is one of the most press the
prestigious even Sanchez and making my
debut is really special for sure
and also it's special for your fans and
I was wondering since which age do you
remember actually about the existence of
grantchester when did you start to
follow the events of grantchester do you
remember any specific event
I think I started like
a few years back I don't remember
exactly but uh yeah I do follow all the
all the events and
especially since like granchester has
like most of the top 10 players so many
strong players it's it's of course a
nice event to follow and
um I mean especially in Zagreb there was
a very nice event which Magnus dominated
in 2019 that remember that event I
remember quite quite well yeah that's
great and also this event is very
special also because we shall not
displayed here right and you're going to
play together in the same tournament
have it ever happened before and what
are you thinking about it the fact that
you played together with vision yeah of
course we've interacted a lot we've
trained together we've played some
training games but this is going to be
my first time in a tournament game
actually and yeah I can't be more
excited for it yes I mean three games
with me yeah where are you dreaming
about it before I mean at the start I
couldn't even dream about it but
but yeah I like
hey I've always wanted to play play him
in a tournament game and
I have an opportunity here and this is
there's going to be like
um a lot of fun and uh
yeah hopefully we'll play some very nice
games yeah we hope so too for sure and I
was also wondering what was your
preparation the preparational routine
over this years I know that you were not
using for some favorite computers I mean
how new technologies affected your
preparation and do you use it now right
now
yeah till the pandemic started I have I
wasn't really working with computers but
after that I'm
working with computers regularly
I mostly use them for openings and like
I mean preparation for this
for this tournament it's been just a
some openings and puzzles and Playing
Games
Etc
yeah and my last question you know in
this event and many others from the
young age you have to play against
really strong opponents higher rated and
you know many kids many young players
they have this fear to play with high
rated stronger opponents how do you
fight with those fears I mean what what
do you tell to yourself I mean how do
you go through all this
I guess I'm I'm experience than if not
to like fear stronger opponents I mean I
I used to do that when I was very young
but
I guess I've gotten used to it you know
what how do you get this self-confidence
I guess once you start beating opponents
uh higher returns it's uh
it's just uh I guess it's just
experience yeah that's great I mean just
start beating them and you feel much
better and more confident yes so thank
you so much and very appreciate your
answers and all the best of luck in your
first GCT web yeah thank you
[Music]
welcome back everyone after six very
exciting rounds of Blitz these are our
standings Nasi Magnus has extended his
lead as he won six games in a row today
very impressive Yani pong she's still in
the second place and Fabiano in third
and it's coming down to this this round
seven pairing is mouth-watering as the
world's number one rated Blitz player by
reading alireza plain one and only
Magnus Carlson exactly who's six out of
six can he equal the Fabby streak of
seven out of seven what else is
happening in the tournament the pulasko
will be playing Anand Duda facing sorry
chickens Carolina and the Palm is
chickens report so it may be the Magnus
Carlson show but there was some exciting
uh excitement going on in fabby's last
round game and I think we've got
something to show you let's have a look
oh yeah this madness
[Laughter]
uh somehow fobby
blundered the game away and then forgot
to play King F2 first exactly for
promoting and the two players were just
so happy that the torture was over there
at the very end as the players made a
draw getting ready for this round seven
uh I said mouth-watering mirror I mean
what are the way would you describe it
as far Asia has to win if he's going to
stop the Magnus train absolutely right
so it's Fairuza who's under pressure
it's well Nepal and perhaps Wishy
looking to win you know to bounce back
and Magnus looks Unstoppable if you ask
me right he said it and he's doing it
right six out of six uh to make such a
streak you need
your confidence obviously skills
obviously but a lot of luck things have
just gone uh flowingly well
I mentioned that good cash is one one of
the very first players to arrive I just
noticed that alireza in this for this
round I'll arrive very early and for
this round Magnus Carlson is not late
as both of the players are at the board
with several minutes to spare and you
were talking about getting lucky in some
games and Fairuza got very lucky against
Anand in the last round it was
remarkable he was the exchange down and
he and Vichy just walked into a one move
blender
a fork and it had to give it up on the
spot
uh jump in on this one
um Miro alireza
uh what has he scored out of the six
games he's played we know what Magnus
scored
is it five out of six followers I think
it is yeah I think it is that's that's
that's impressive as well but did he
start with the loss no he lost against
Richie upper Rook yes in round three
that's right okay yes he was upper so
these two players are actually
uh you know result wise I want to say
the hottest in the field and it could be
it could have been that there could both
be 6-0
I mean had the Richie report go go his
way
first draw of the game yeah do the math
uh Ali Raza had nine points in the rapid
uh he's increased his uh current score
total to 14 that means he scored five
out of six and after Magnus 11. we're
off another 17. and another Karen Khan
well it seems like when Magnus wants to
play for a win
[Music]
I've never seen this move it might
already be a novelty
whoa
F2 F3 the fantasy variation Queen A5
check move I haven't completely
unfamiliar with and then E5 so I played
the car account my whole life and on
move four uh they have a completely new
position for my actually on move three
Queen A5 that's not been played and
mirror you want to say that this is like
in the database no it's not it's not
Queen A5 well at least in Masters
database probably some you know Park
costlos played it against each other but
yeah but you know you see it for the
first time you think well I'm playing
the beginner he sees Jack he goes check
right but that's Magnus Carson we're
talking about and then came C3 and then
came E5 and I've got a feeling that at
least Ali raises freewheeling it here
with b2b4 sorry if I say it's Phil's
Coffee House you see you mentioned the
park but I'll take it indoors and say it
feels a little coffee house going on
look at the White Spot structure first
five moves it's been before D4 E4 and
c3f3 this does not look right right let
me just tell the audience learn to play
with your pieces
it's not all pawn play Queen takes E5
no I don't like why did we move
the queen he's quite strange to me
we we centralize the queen that can't be
right uh Bishop to E3 on the board okay
the question is can I get away with just
simply Knight F6 now hanging can you
take Bishop B4 or is that oh you have F
wait
should D4 I have F4 but Bishop C3 check
and I'll move my king queen
oh and I I have to move my king to E2
no I can't so Bishop B4 I have Queen d4s
oh they have 92. right
but you have queen of sex so Bishop B4
F4 you know Bishop C3 better to avoid
the 45 I'll take on e4 first then I'll
take on B4 so take on e4 take on e4
Bishop B4 bit now you're allowed Knight
F3 okay Bishop C3 check I'll move my
king he's done you remove a D5 takes E4
I have to play a if you're going to play
the Fantasy variation by the way you
don't even think about it you play F3 he
didn't take on B4 what would have
happened after Knight F3
Magnus would have been up
and you're experts
right after three Bishop takes C3 check
that would have been a very interesting
line none of that excitement happened
Knight F3 Queen C7 but now castles and
Knight G5 and maybe Ali raises
landing on his feet
okay Queen C7 there was opportunity
there I think for Magnus but uh he let
the moment slide
and I'd have three Quincy seven I'm
gonna bet this is going to be an
opposite side Castle game and
with blacks going first with black going
long and white going short yeah okay
well let's have some fun guys
and clock times I mean the
it's only four five six moves but they
spent a lot of time getting here that is
true so firusha is down to three minutes
and Magnus three minutes 40 seconds
three minutes 40 seconds so we do have
Knight G5 on the board you didn't want
to play Bishop dd6 because there was
ideas that the queen could land on H5
with a check yeah Knight takes Queen H5
check and queen H3 so Knight F6
uh Bishop F4 looks good Bishop F4 looks
great
um 56 seconds oh he took only six right
away yeah I I'm I'm trying to combine
some ideas here with Bishop C4 and
Bishop F4 so if it's my turn Bishop F4
is huge so you have to play Bishop D6 uh
you're prepared to give up the E6 Pawn
or trade the E6 Pawn for the H2 Pawn so
here is your take on E6 give up H2 and
then King H1 castles long like you said
right yeah you got to get your king out
of Dodge
to develop very quickly on the queen
side
true
is G3 an option or magnesium
mystery
I think it's an option actually uh as as
is well H3 Bishop H2 and Knight E4 I
have to be careful about that but I
don't see it an alternative here to
Bishop E6
because I don't have it I mean I don't
have a convenient my night's not on D2
so I can't conveniently defend H2 with
Knight F3
and the clock uh early raises yeah he's
taking a long thing and it's a minute 44
now a minute 44 hard for me to tell from
my angle I'm seeing just 30 seconds I
don't see them he's uh down two minutes
now and he's done what you've suggested
G3 because H3
too many dark Square weaknesses over
there if Bishop G3 he can take back
right
Magnus doesn't take I think he was ready
just to play Queen E2 and end up
capturing the pawn on E6 he's taken on
E6 right away so Bishop takes G3 is now
on still and very possible and queen E2
or queen C2 right one of them yes well
I would think so here is rookie Eight
coming in right that's an important
Tempo uh to be asked Rook E8 he's played
it
I mean Black's development and position
looks much better yes no question about
it and uh
from from a development perspective with
you know it looks like a Fisher random
now maybe
describe upon sure take the pawn so
but White's development about four times
disaster disaster
disaster
the good news for white at the moment is
actually the king is in a little bit of
an awkward pin
but that's the only negative I can think
of at the moment for for for black
everything else is just fantastic
very quickly
yes you know it's a bad way yeah you
know it's bad when you start thinking
okay I can defend laterally with Rook A2
but you know what now that you mention
it that might be
one of the best choices also something
to be said for Queen C2 maybe just
getting getting out of the University
down to 33 seconds
aggressively and yes dropped a piece but
King B8 yep just sidestepping by the way
check and Knight E5 I'm not sure I like
Rook D7 oh he's just his intention was
to trade but I mean because trading all
his good pieces which was the rook and
the bishop and he's left with this
undeveloped Queen side
it's not a good thing
if you're alireza oh uh he's luring the
queen to the D file so that at least he
has Bishop F4 because Bishop C5 oh
there's no
I thought the same thing Bishop C5 check
but you're not allowed according to the
fide rules to leave your king hanging
so Magnus was thinking maybe he was
considering Bishop takes G3
but he ended up changing and now Bishop
F4 so it's still yeah I'll erase it is
is doing his desperate best to equalize
the position how do we equalize it I
don't know completely he's going to play
Knight A3
King G2 94 and
goodbye yeah he's grabbed his Knight
we are playing touch move 10 seconds on
the clock Knight A3 as you said Queen E3
and Knight E4 this is turning out to be
a very easy game for Magnus truly
uh Magnus is making it looks three
making it look simple Queen E2 check and
White's King is about to be blasted yeah
I think we need to check at night to do
yes precisely we need to check King G1
Knight D2 threatening Knight F3 and
that's lights out
uh anything else
you'd almost suspect that there's
there's got to be several wins here but
uh
well wanna one is enough just grabbing
the pawn also I've noticed Magnus has
been just going into end games
by the way we do have a result that nepo
and Richie report did make a draw in
their game Magnus invited an ending you
were about to say Nasi yeah he's been uh
exchange trading queens and just going
into winning and
right so but and it's worked out well
for him hasn't it it certainly has six
out of six okay In This Moment again the
king I I would I'd be all over Queenie
for check here we need to as well
because they don't have Rook F2 white oh
who takes that too oh you're absolutely
right yeah I I wanted to I was thinking
that if I go Queenie two check he'll go
King G1 so if I go Queen E4 check King
G1 I'll have Knight E2 check
Magnus played A6 just opening a window
for his game
exactly making love but Queenie for
check it looks winning everything looks
winning well yeah Queen e4king H3 I
guess and then we have a rook left right
King h35 yeah
just to make a thread of uh Rook up and
over so if you want rookie six I think I
can grow
up the rookie five looks
three words
rookie pie and could this be Miro could
this be seven for seven what the heck is
it is definitely what the heck is going
on
uh H5
in this game yeah any takers for H5
the queen is the H5 on the board and
H4 and no time no time at all for Ali
Reza and this game was very very
one-sided very one-sided game and Knight
E4
B4 was just really
yeah really bad in the opening true so
you can go Queen takes G4 I think that
would provoke resignation but Magnus is
looking for a force mate and I would be
surprised if it wasn't there actually
check check yeah
sometimes uh you can Overlook the fact
that it's Czech right and then he's up
like three million pounds
three is enough million sounds excessive
okay so you just oh seven out of seven
meanwhile Vision has drawn his game
against lupulasco
down to 10 seconds but he does not need
much time to win this game
I don't know why he hasn't pushed the
pawns yet exactly like what the heck I
mean everything is winning White Knight
is not getting out maybe Knight C2
B4
B3
there's no crazy tactics here right
because uh you can take the Knight
Black's Pawn is faster so exactly
and uh Papi won his game nice comeback
wonderful who did he beat Yvonne sarage
by the way the night it makes a
beautiful impression just defending the
king against all the checks you can play
A5 A4 and uh Ali Reza had enough and I
tell you that was an incredibly smooth
game what other games are going on at
the moment when dudas games still going
let's jump there to against good cash
and
two extra pawns for good cash and an
exposed uh an exposed King and just to
remind everybody Fabi did win and Duda
goes down
oh it's not been a good good day at all
for uh polish Grandmaster
uh superlatives we're running out of
things to say about magnus's result he's
just
well let's look at the line score you
can it it speaks for itself no
no words necessary you shouldn't want
every single game today but it wasn't
all easy breezy he was definitely lost
it in a couple of them yeah no he's this
last game uh you saw him at his absolute
best and yes he's gotten lucky to get
the seven out of seven but there were a
few games that were drawn and he just
outplayed upon it in just last couple of
moves
um miros
superlative it's extraordinary uh well
what you want me to say yes I'm very
happy despite you know respectable age
I'm very good at memorizing stuff I know
exactly what result Magnus had in all
seven games today
that's easy your memory is excellent
yeah see uh right I mean if you allow me
I know you've covered this one
extensively but just just you know Queen
A5 being in novelty is already moved
three right then B4 apparently is a very
bad move then you guys you were much
more precise than the players so D takes
Pawn takes Bishop B4 was good what was
playable it was good not playable but
good good right after Bishop D3 A5 was
even like stronger and black much better
and so on right and and then
interestingly over here the Reza's
position is actually good and the
mistake was the very you know very
natural move to Castle short so compie
says you had to go here you had to take
I mean you started to play this game we
weirdly just continue to play weirdly
Queen B3 you attack this and you are
actually planning for Castle long
develop the bishop Knight D2 Castle long
okay relatively equal but if anyone's
better it's white and then when he
Castle short from then on Magnus well
maybe a couple of inaccuracies but
always had alireza
wow all right and then well well they've
just pardon me one more thing it's
reports game against Nepal that was very
interesting because well Keynes Indian
from report nepo I didn't expect him to
play D4 first of all right and I think
he never came up with a novelty and
maybe a good one okay it's not the most
popular position by any stretch of
imagination but Knight to G5 has never
happened before and then yeah usually in
the king's Indian when you exchange
those Bishops it's in White's favor
which he could have proved by the way a
few moves later so here nepo went
Queenie 2 and later on was you know
under some pressure and he could have
gone King F1 and it's not very often
that it works in the king's Indian but
apparently it works here and you just
run away because the king queen side is
safe right black doesn't have the light
Square bishop and White's prospects
would have been better in this case
yeah so that's all I've got for now
thank you Mero and let's remind our
viewers that you are watching the Magnus
Carlson show as we show you our
standings you'll see why we call it the
Magnus Carlson show keeps extending his
lead now with the two and a half points
right yes and the six support me the
seven in a row that he's just scored has
just been uh beautiful to witness as
we're going to toss it to Zagreb and
ask them what they what do you guys
think of Magnus Carlson not bad eh
actually you know remember that in
Warsaw he didn't like to check the
standings now I see him all the time
he's checking the standings you know it
is because he's leading her that wild
card is pretty good I have to say uh
let's talk about the other two games
that we didn't get covered the one
between here and do cash and this was a
completely back and forth affair take a
look at this Knight to H5 it seems like
white is doing just fine not after this
move E3 this pretty much locks your own
Bishop in place and immediately gookish
pounces on the opportunity with the move
G5 and F6
at least Queen to G6 was mandatory at
this point if you don't want to get into
a much worse maybe borderline losing
position Knight to G7 and this is the
key move that you have to see from afar
Bishop to H3 is pretty much impossible
to see it because if you take then I
take and you're actually getting
checkmated yourself as black and if you
do F5 at least my Bishop on E5 survives
so that's good news for my Bishop it
still looks very shaky with that Queen
on G6 anything can happen right anything
can get trapped but he played the move
G4
and now Gucci had an amazing opportunity
to get probably what is the most
visually appealing position that you can
get close to it in chess G4 take a look
at this position you cannot untie
yourself with the white pieces no more
F3 all I have to do is pick up this port
on H5 I'm going to do so after the move
Queen to E8 Queen takes H5 Knight to F6
if you try to defend it as well it
doesn't really matter you just simply
don't have any counter play so this is
pretty much game over he didn't play the
move G4
he played uh excuse me that was uh Queen
to E8 and then allowed white to play the
move F3 and untie himself after which it
was white was winning at some point take
a look at this this is already much
better for white you're getting great
great attacking chances on the f file
also the queen could potentially at some
point land on G6 take a look at this
queen to C2 you take my Pawn on E5 with
a rook to F6 Rook to F1 do not touch
this uh Bishop because after Queen to G6
this is pretty much game over you get
checkmated afterward to F7 he didn't so
white is completely winning at this
point Queen takes G5 Bishop to H3 a huge
mistake in the position what he had to
do was in fact play the move Rook one to
F4 it's all about that Rook to G6
yes yes and even if you don't do
anything I do have a threat Knight to F3
it's all about diverting uh this knight
from E5 so that I can play the move Rook
to G6 you can play whatever or 27 let's
say Knight to F3 and Rook to G6 is going
to come next so golden opportunity play
the move Bishop to H3 and unfortunately
this is what he missed came to H2 it
looks like you have a tremendous attack
Rook to A7 defends everything on Seventh
rank I'm actually going to go Rook to G7
which he did later on and your attack is
pretty much over the bishop on H3 is not
playing an important part I'm the one
attacking you on the king side now
because I'm going to go route to G8
Queen to G3 as we can see and in fact it
was googesh who checkmated or at least
gotten close to it before uh Duda resign
he actually just took all of his pawns
and then resignation came later on
Anastasia what we're looking at I was
checking the game of 5V once again and
maybe I should stop doing it because
let's say he has such a wet positions
all the time at the opening but then
something happens he the producers of
the show survival should definitely
think of bringing him to the show I I
think because look at this position he
got after the opening um yeah it looked
a little bit suspicious with his skin
gonna fade and he got inspired by his
game
it looks like a couple of rounds ago yes
we saw similar uh
his opponents played the movie before
and I think really he got really good
position and um okay the pawn structure
is a little bit different but still I
mean white we're doing really really
well in the whole game basically for the
most of the game but then somehow what
did I told you yes we discussed it with
Christian and Christian said wait he
will come back to the game and he will
even win I don't know how he's doing it
definitely he has maybe better time
management because he had more time at
this moment so but he managed to come
back I mean you see the swindles yeah
back and forth in every single game it's
all about the time absolutely yes and I
mean it's it's hard to say what was this
moment when black finally managed to to
find his control by basic somewhere here
when he pushed his Pawn forward and got
this kind of very strong sensor and
after that he
even managed to win this game yes so
great once you get the spawns like this
I mean this is looking really good right
yes it looked dangerous after that even
though white has despawned on G6 it just
helps black to blockade the GE file
Fabi it doesn't really matter right now
is the Magnus show we have to say seven
out of seven he's stealing all the
spotlight and he sort of predicted it
yesterday in the interview guys back
here
thank you so much and it is the Magnus
Carlson show as you'll see from the
standings Nancy do the honors it's
really remarkable right Magnus Carlson
in the lead with 18
and Sharon second Fabiano caruana and
Yani promise but it'll be very hard for
them to catch Magnus well tell us about
the pairings for round eight the next
round coming up
Carlton will be facing report we'll have
to watch and see Richie's moment in the
Limelight and then uh people who are
sharing the second place karwana and
publisher facing each other obviously
our Marquee match up as well that will
be our second and how about the rest of
the deal go cash playing sorry I'm not
playing Duda in firusha against lupus
wonderful we're going to take a very
short break and we'll see you on the
other side as we get ready for round
eight of the blitz coming up
[Music]
thank you
Constantine great to see you here in
Croatia welcome to grantchester once
again but in 2022 uh in Paul in Poland I
think on Romania you have played already
first time uh how was it can you
remember yeah a little bit just amazing
feeling I mean to play all these great
players just after pandemics so it was
just fantastic yes I mean and that
experience do you think it's going to
help you now for sure because then okay
I remember first first game I played
against aronia and I mean I was like
okay I'm playing this fantastic players
in this unique event because okay of
course I played them before but on
separate events let's see one game one
at a time and then it's different but to
play them all I mean one event it's it's
a one one thing one it's amazing yes and
here we're going to have a different
time control it's gonna be rabbit and
Blitz do you think you play better with
short time controls I think it depends a
lot of you know one's form I mean I
tried my best to let's say achieve let's
say top form now I will see how
yeah how did you manage to do so no I
took a special training camp or
something no I had some training camps
with my friends I played a lot of Rapids
and Blitz so yeah I saw also with you
today David gavril lesko from Romania
young player Grandmaster who also
participated in cranchester before
um is he your second here yeah his acts
as my second yeah what what do you think
he's going to do during this tournament
and is it really helpful to have a
second during rapid and Blitz events I
think uh okay mostly most of the work he
did before I mean helping me up with
openings and playing some training games
but also here I mean I think uh it's
very good to have somebody for support
because it can be let's say you play
very fast and some sudden you know
result could be could go both ways and
if it goes let's see some unfortunate
way then it's good to have somebody
around you to lift you up that's for
sure do you think it's going to be also
a great experience for him yeah I think
yeah I mean he has also experience as a
player so also the I think it should be
also nice for him you're living in
Romania and over the years do you feel
that chess is actually booming now in
Romania I mean it's fantastic I mean
it's the last since back in 21 I mean we
got this amazing support from you know
from all these our partners and
especially dragon's family it was just
just amazing the support we're getting
now yeah now you have a really strong
team
I mean we have reached report to have
worked on Deck we have chefchenko kiril
so I mean what are your goals now you
know for Olympia for European okay
Europe Olympia will be one year away but
I guess we should aim for getting a
medal I mean in a European team event I
mean we have I think we're starting top
six at least wow and actually what's
happening with youth chess maybe you can
tell a little bit about it uh you just
okay I am not that familiar with uh I
mean they have their let's say their
program but I know they brought some
very experienced coaches like Ramesh
also I think captain of Romanian team
Ivan sokolov was working a lot of
youngsters so yeah you can also expect
some some talents coming up especially
if one is involved yes yes we know he's
yeah yeah of course results with
Uzbekistan team yeah so the last
question is simply like what you're
looking forward to achieving this event
just want to you know to play my best
chess to enjoy all this fantastic event
with all these top players yeah thank
you Constantine thank you best of luck
thank you
[Music]
it's welcome back to our show as seven
incredible eventful Blitz rounds have
featured Magnus cars all seven games all
seven games really truly remarkable and
Sharon's second Fabiano and Johnny
palmniche in clear fourth alireza
ferrusha and in fifth place is Richie
Rapport who will be playing Magnus
Crossing tell us more tell us about the
round eight pairings coming up and other
players are hoping that someone can stop
somebody better start to stop the Magnus
Carlson train because this has been
amazing so our two key matchups will be
Carlson report and karwana exactly and
non-dude of both of those two players
are dating farouzia having lost to
Magnus needs to bounce back but yeah
it's about to fight for second at the
moment somebody's got to stop Magnus
Carlson wow as the players get ready for
this our penultimate uh round of the day
it's a double round robin in the blitz
will be featuring nine rounds of Blitz
this is round eight coming up nine
rounds of Blitz tomorrow and that will
round out the tournament
what are the chances Magnus finishes 9
out of nine today
well if you said it to me before the
round started I would set zero like no
you just can't win not you know in
modern chess that's not the way it works
uh no no no no but now you start with
seven out of seven
yeah you you get on this role where uh
Suddenly It's it's doable now having
said that Richie Rapport is one of those
players that he can shock you uh Miro
jump in on this one if somebody's gonna
stop Magnus Richie could be that someone
yeah but any anyone can be that someone
yet the result is remarkable but if you
if you recall sorry Chad like winning
moments and so it's all it takes you
know one moment you lose concentration
and your opponent finds it exactly and
they're off and we have an alkyne as you
were saying Mira this used to be a
childhood favorite of yours huh
absolutely yeah like I played it as well
alakai defense and uh at those days
people didn't play positionally people
played C4 and F4 and it was the four
pawns attack that everybody uh studied
but these days it's about positional uh
chess
and this is Robert's third or fourth
time trying this opening in this
tournament and he's mixed it up here
he's he Enchanted his Bishop uh in
previous games he was playing it with E6
yeah
so uh the difference is that well
obviously you leave this diagonal open
you're hoping that uh your Bishop will
either land on E6 or even on a good day
you might be able to play moves like
night before and the bishop could land
on F5 in the meanwhile it's sort of like
okay White
the e-file
the Knight slowly slowly starts jumping
towards the king side Knight D2 night
night E4 you centralize the pieces and
black finds it a little bit awkward uh
this Pawn on D4 is Black's main idea
here to successfully push C5
if you can get that in that that would
be definitely a very very big success
Knight takes D7 by the way at first
glance you might say to yourself well
that's that's a concession and yes it is
but you mentioned that you wanted to
play the move C5 and the Knight on D7
actually did support it so if you play
Bishop takes D7 Knight comes to D2
h2h3 the Knight comes to F3 and you
still haven't played C5 your Bishop for
the moment so if you want to save a
Tempo on H3 you could go Knight c495
there you go and I do want to save that
Tempo I like it Knight C4 Knight E5
because I'm not 100 sure
um
I need H3 some on some days in in
different galaxies
sometimes I actually want to play H4 and
H5 by the way Magnus inviting the move
Bishop G4 and I'm assuming now we're
gonna see H3 and then we get the two
Bishops
we do get white has now a long-term
Advantage which is called Bishop pair
exactly
in your expert opinion
uh E7 E6 and uh even the old guys uh
used to call it winning the minor
exchange they felt the two Bishops were
so strong uh winning the exchange sounds
really good you've never heard that
minor exchange the minor exchange yeah
uh E5 I'm a little bit surprised by that
move but uh
I kind of understand that you want to
play forcing but E5
he went to get rid of that E7 Pawn but
yeah whites definitely I'm not sure this
look I mean it it makes my play as white
so much easier when you played the move
E5 I was thinking for sure Richie was
about to play E7 E6 and angle for C5 he
didn't do that and after Bishop C4 we
understand exactly what Magnus is
thinking bring the pieces into Play
Bishop H6 Rook to D1 and enjoy uh
two Bishops the Knight on D5 was
the anchor position yes and now that
it's shaky yeah we gotta wobble
okay he has a
little idea he's inviting uh just King
F1 exactly he's inviting white to win a
pawn do we want to play with the King on
E1
I guess we have to uh by the way we
could play Just Pawn G3 I was thinking
actually rookie eight Bishop H6 anyway
right uh an answer to rookie eight I
wasn't thinking of taking but he did so
he just put the bishop on H6 uh rookie
eight Bishop takes D5 we're looking at
Bishop H2 King F1 rookie one king he won
thanks
and our King is on E1 there's a bishop
on H2 maybe I have G3 G3 might be
the old Bobby Fisher no he drives the
slow right I have rookie a check but you
have Bishop E3 as well as king F1 and
back to G2 so Bishop H Richie Richie's
probably just gonna have to recapture
the bishop and say okay if you want to
win a pawn be my guest
he's taking a long thing so now he's he
has two minutes less than magazine I did
play Bishop H2 uh this again at the end
of the day this move G2 G3 is going to
snare the bishop
G2 G3 how do we save that Bishop right
how do we that's that's Richard
definitely says something so it has to
be associated with Queen C4 because G3
okay check King F1 Quincy for check King
G2 and rookie one
engage two queen of wow
no so it doesn't work it doesn't work
that's what I'm saying but maybe he's
thinking G3 Queen C4
he's here what we're about to find out I
think Richie's got to play because we're
looking at rookie a check King F1 Queen
C4 check King G2 Rook E1 take the bishop
so I saw it on miro's board he was
showing after Queen F1 Queen G2 that is
Queen E2
and that's fine for black no way really
oh that's remarkable computer magic
right oh
uh by the way Richie
running down his clock very very
seriously three minutes to a minute and
a half it looks like
and that's the only way to save that
piece um you might find it because there
is nothing else right but that last name
of Queenie too because it still doesn't
make sense why is it okay I guess you're
threatening Rook F1 right and I I can't
move my Rook on the bishop right or the
queen
sure that's not bad but I can go G4 and
King G3 yeah
uh by the way Bishop E3
whoa we just saw something happen Bishop
E3 Bishop takes G3 instantly and the
point is there's a queen B6 and queen
takes B2
Magnus something yes Bishop G3 is great
Magnus is is Hedges seemed to go into
his hands already better rapper's doing
great whoa so uh that was a big Miss
Bishop E3 by the way big update Duda
already
in that game as well
and
it just feels like that she's running
out of energy a little bit as he
struggles in the blitz but Bishop takes
G3 and Richie is suddenly back in the
game the bishop is released he's won a
pawn he's a healthy extra Pawn exactly
and whoa Magnus the streak is under
threat yeah Bishop can go to B8 now or
D6 looks fine well I see A7 saying it's
ah the training
yes uh but 40 seconds to play fast
40 seconds oh my gosh
uh against 200
two and a half he played Bishop to E5
inviting Bishop A7 why
not sure because Bishop A7 maybe okay
eight ah simple chess
although it's not that simple is it I
have Queen E3 Queenie three I have Queen
oh wait Magnus spider rookie one that's
a good move okay seven rookie five and
then D5 hangs so precise
I guess Magnus is back
it's equal right yeah Rook takes A7 Rook
takes E5 and there's ideas of Queen F6
as well Rook takes A2 for example Rook
tape and black would try F6 here and we
have Bishop takes C3
Rook to E7 ding ding ding there's a make
seven you have D4
Rook E7 rookie seven Rook E7 is winning
for white of course Magnus plays it Rook
E7 and by the way if you play D4 I can
play Queen takes B7
yep that hits the Rook The Bishop's
under attack and Richie has fallen into
a horrendous trap the streak is back
eight out of eight
unbelievable and black doesn't even have
any checks or anything it's just game
over I I'm watching this and I'm still
disbelieving it's
you know Richie was just a full Pawn up
and a good position if he had played
Bishop B Bishop B8 there'd be no
discussions but Queen takes B7
and look at this The Rook is hanging the
bishop is hanging you're forced to give
up the exchange and he's done it okay
he's hoping for Queen A7 Queen D5 check
oh by the way Queen Shaq and queen E5
check
that's nasty six and you take with the
Rook on A7 that's correct that's exactly
much improved and Magnus is sensing it
as well he doesn't have to take on A7
but Queen B8 check just everything seems
to be going
in magnus's oh he he took okay
surprise as I said that right
commentators we're just uh so pleased
with ourselves that we found this very
nice idea and he rejected it he just
took the roof I guess it's 12 seconds 10
seconds
D3
on C3 oh D2 wow this Pawn is just paid
suddenly on your doorstep like what
happened
D3 so we we do have Queen D7 by the way
uh okay Queen de salmon would
probably if
it's a five check and
check it's not it's all yeah it's not
exactly what we wanted right Bishop E5
Chuck by the way D2 how do we stop this
problem well he played do you want Quinn
that's the question why can't we just
make a queen we can't
five seconds
is it back in three seconds down upon by
The White's King is completely open that
was a that was very very bizarre why did
he take the bishop on C3 he gave back
the exchange
by the way uh Ali Reza has won his game
against Constantine check 24 seconds to
still not easy
or two seconds
but A4 allows Queen C5 with a double
attack we're hitting F2 oh excuse me I
missed yeah there's checks now
wow Magnus let Richard Escape truly
so I think your move Queen D7 was just
finished in the game finishing it yeah
but we've seen
Magnus won a queen ending I believe
against Fabiana earlier today and it was
some kind of magic that occurred there
so he needs to pull another magic trick
to win this one exactly well he's moved
this King over C4 check don't forget it
okay I can see that he can pull this off
as well well I mean
he's got passers but this move F5 is an
indication that hey I've got a passer as
well
so F3 A7 very long time three seconds
G5 exposing this game put in the queen
on F3 was probably bad because
that's a check
it's a check every five threatening
Queen B6 and six seconds for Magnus
they're both with five seconds now oh my
goodness anything can happen here one
second one second three seconds one
second
three seconds again King F2 this is hard
to watch three seconds again
Magnus three seconds
check
hold on
oh Queen E5 couldn't be eight why
wow okay just is there check my oh queen
of three
and you're threatening mate on G4
Magnus has done the impossible he's won
eight in a row and let's just uh wow
Fabi against Nepal we have rook and
Bishop the fight for second place uh
comes down to rook and Bishop
Nepal can save this even with few
seconds on the clock I'm sure he can
laughs
crickets
uh King yes uh good move King B4 and
then wait I like the um
idea with King and Rook being just one
square part I think that's the easier
defense I've always liked this what was
called the Zen position s z e n not Zen
as in z-e-n but there was a player Zen
who studied this ending and it has a
defense for this ending named after and
I learned that defense and I thought it
really really excellent
now big question is who is counting the
50 moves because and by the way uh the
way nepo is playing is really
extraordinarily exacting amazing very
very good uh play I would say with the
bishop with the Rook Against The Rook I
think they still have third
Rich move 50 . King uh pardon me Rook at
four yeah
look very very good the key for nepo is
to not go down to five seconds then it
can easily blunder exactly
whoa Rook
f8 I'm sure that was a saving move as
well I didn't well
here anyways right yes five minutes
together King over to H one corner oh
okay now he's claiming a draw
he just wants to see how many moves have
oh I think I think that's he has the
right to ask is that right Miro that he
has the right to ask the Arbiter yeah
right I guess like the punishment if the
claim is false it will be some time
added to fabi's clock that's right right
and then it's not a punishment if you
know the position is drawish right and
you know how to make it rule so you just
uh well want yourself some time to you
know to relax and also you will know
what well yeah like what what move
number there is Let's help our viewers
what move number is it when what was the
last Exchange
move 54 is when they last traded and
what move were they on currently
so they've made 34 moves so they only
have to make 16 more
Arbiters are doing the math
toe
exactly that I think that's that's
exactly it he starts counting 16. uh
that's an easier oh and karwana didn't
get any additional time no he was simply
asking
he was asking about the um I didn't know
you could just stop the clock and ask
Arbiter a question
yes you're
you're able to do that good to know good
to know in the classical tour just
please well in classical
and by the way that looks like 16 moves
not yet okay there yes it's on 99 now
54 is
90. but yeah I don't think if I was
making any progress so this should be an
easy draw
20 seconds to seven
seven seconds but yeah there's no
progress and yeah the game is leeches is
telling me it's already a draw
they made 50 moves and by the way
they've got the Zen ending again this is
the only draw in is round four other
decisive results
wow
and it's funny because they've gone way
past
uh I mean if you knew you had you needed
16 moves uh and the Arbiters ever
interfere or no I think the Arbiters
interfere at move 75.
oh we might get there
we might get their attention very
quickly
now nepo is not even
nepo's not even claiming what
yeah that was pretty uh our only draw
around
wow and again for those of you who are
joining us late shame on you we're we're
witnessing his historical result just
there's no other way of putting it eight
out of eight Miro uh
what what have we missed in the other
games
uh well I had my eyes on fabi's game
against nepo first of all and you know
if not for this funny end game I would
have said that okay it was a fair draw
very you know equalish rise from the
start but I was one very exciting game
between
um gukesh and sarich and I believe if
you were following the broadcast you are
familiar with this position it's been
played on a couple of occasions and
white was always playing Bishop D2 and I
was
I was you know advertising that in case
of f4 black could sacrifice in exchange
no the answer is no sarich has his own
opinion so H6 in fact this line is just
as popular as sacrificing The Exchange
King B1 Queen C5 Queen D2 and the key
move here is F5 interestingly it might
seem like it's a big mistake y just goes
E5 and so on but this position black
sacrifices the opponent it turns out
that it's more than playable for black
so the bishop is very powerful the D6
Pawn is weak so this would be more than
acceptable
right and later on later on yeah there
have been a lot of stuff happening
over there white got totally outplayed
go cash got totally outplayed sarich
comes in with sort of a decisive blow
Rook takes C3 you cannot take back the
verb because Queen takes F4 F6 happens
so now everything is hanging in the
position right The Bishop's hanging
Bishop H7 is a threat the Queen's gonna
be hanging
Rook to B8 King A1 and now the move that
would have won and of course we are not
talking classical chess that's hard to
find but Queen F4 Queen F4 Bishop F6
would be totally winning for black
despite only having a rook and a few
pawns for the queen because the king is
too bad so Rook C4 this pin will decide
he has played Bishop F6 I don't know if
he blundered the queen I don't think so
simply couldn't find the better move and
few moves later
a few moves later he was already white
he was playing for a win
until the moment where go cash just
played Queen this queen D5 totally
blundering the game away Rook B1 King A2
Bishop to E6 so well if not for this
moment where sarich couldn't find the
best move that would have been one of
his best games there but at least he's
getting the win anyway
all right and I think we still have
quite some time before the last round
today so let's go to Creation once again
guys how lucky you are to witness eight
out of eight by Magnus Carlsen
no absolutely this is a history in the
making and I'm pretty sure this might be
a record for the grandchester when it
comes to uh streaks of a player Magnus
is just absolutely incredible and let's
not forget he also won at least the last
game of Rapid yesterday so right now
he's on a nine game winning streak I'm
not gonna jinx it but he is playing a
very struggling uh opponent in the final
round he's playing lupuscu so he has a
pretty decent chance of scoring 10 out
of 10 perhaps exactly and then he will
not sleep we remember what happened with
this title Tuesday when he couldn't
sleep after 11 out of 11 so you can lose
your sleep easily after such a day right
that is pretty sick anyway uh let's go
to the game between Ali Reza and
Constantine lupuscu one game by the way
alireza is also doing great in this
event he's keeping Pace trying to keep
Pace at least with the leader Magnus and
this was the critical position after
Bishop to C6 by the way lupus school
once again he's playing really good
openings getting good positions out of
the opening unfortunately for him in the
middle game he just gets lost queen to
B6 was the wrong move right idea wrong
move you do have to exchange the light
Square Bishops but you have to do it
with Bishop takes G2 and then Queen to
B6 and the idea is that with the queen
on B6 and the pawn on B7 instead of C6
as we will see in the game The Pawn on
E6 is protected so now you don't have to
play the move E5 that was a big problem
in the game because after Bishop takes
E6 Rook to E1 now you have to go E5 but
this weakens the light squares I go
Knight to F5 and this is just a very
very dangerous position he did manage to
defend at all because it's almost
impossible to defend it in a classical
game is difficult in a rapid or Blitz
game is pretty much impossible with so
many weaknesses around your king and
quite a bit of rest and game look at
this King h8 Knight F7 Rook h8 would
have been the end of the game very nice
checkmate for alibreza what game were
you watching on Assassin I was checking
the game which finished pretty fast it
was a game between uh and yankov
just something went wrong for vision
this round I really feel that he
um let's say he's a bit tired and look
what happened here he decided to do the
long castling and do this simply brought
all his pieces to the queen side and
just managed to win the game like that
look at this and actually at the moment
after a few exchanges at the moment when
Bishi resigned nothing it seems like
nothing is happening let's say the the
board is full of pieces but it's just
collapsing it just collapsing because
yes just just made her coming and even
Duda doesn't need to do it he can just
bring Rooks to see it and just you know
enjoy his position for some time he
actually yeah and he just resigned here
after black made the casting I've never
seen something like this before he
decided not even to wait until Duda will
make this last blow
yeah yeah just an incredible game uh but
I do that definitely uh Vichy running
out of steam a little bit but of course
it's the Magnificent show right now
eight out today take a look at his line
score this is just absolutely incredible
yeah and this is not rapid remembering
rapid we were getting two points for a
victory this is the classical scoring
system one one one yes and it's so
simple yes yes even you can remember it
even Afghani remembers
maybe uh next time even Yasser will
remember let's take a look at the
standings Magnus 19 points Fabiano and
Jan 16 alireza 15 points and by the way
he is keep trying to keep Pace still
Four Points behind managed actually to
hold this position look at uh and Bishop
against easily easily he knew he's he
has the Russian School of Chess to a t
we're going to take a quick short break
and we'll be back with the final round
of the day shortly
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
U.S championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out
q-boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
the beauty in Forest Park
it's your move
uni premiere of Chess plays the muni
through July 11th sponsored by St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame for ticketsmuni.org
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen singfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomed chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back after
eight exciting rounds of Blitz these are
our standings and I'll see you do the
honors please Magnus Carlson in the
clear first with three-point lead I mean
it feels like Secretariat Elmont Stakes
as he has taken first place in his grasp
he's not giving it up
and the pairing
can he make it nine out of nine it
wouldn't be a marquee matchup but this
is something historic what would be our
backup game
rapport
sounds good to me as we see to do the
versus farugia and nepo versus goukash
is also very exciting game but we have
some interesting footage of that
previous round NEPA was defending Rook
of Bishop versus Rook oh we won't get to
it we'll leave that for the certain but
here it goes but you could see nepo who
has the draw in his pocket so long as he
doesn't walk into Maiden one
and he seems to be having a smile
enjoying himself
not making a claim
whatever he was thinking right and we're
back to the live board here as uh
Constantine versus uh yes Queens can be
declined exchange variation
and by the way to remind everybody in
the Rapids Constantine was completely
winning there was no question that he
had the game in hand and uh he missed uh
his chance yeah let's put it like that
and then in the end he actually even had
a miracle draw and he missed that as
well so can he improve and can he stop
the perfect streak of Magnus who's eight
out of eight
he played the role of spoiler exactly
well we have a queen's Camp it declined
on the board a slight imbalance in
principle white is considered to have a
little bit of an ad you play Queen C2
you play F2 F3 you bring your Rook to E1
you play for E4 you put your Bishop back
on the F2
yeah I'm not used to seeing the early
Bishop G4 but I liked it that early
exchange of white square Bishops that
Magnus did yeah when in principle if you
can trade off this bishop on C8 for a
bishop on D3 it's in Black's favor to
get rid of those light squared Bishops
now having said that uh
from Magnus point of view it's all about
winning and making something for the
history books uh Miro I'm trying to
think and the only thing I can think
about is the Bobby Fischer Herzog Novi
uh Blitz tournament where we saw
something
extraordinary what we're witnessing
right now
right it's absolutely amazing but once
again I mean how imagine how
disappointed he's gonna be I mean he
still does great in the tournament but
he if he doesn't win against lupulasco
exactly so there is still some pressure
on Magnus maybe not tournament situation
wise but you know yeah going for a
record going after the record he's
always always a stress exactly by the
way F3 B5 on the board as as uh if I'm
white exactly this moment I I kind of my
heart skips a little bit of a beat
because I see that move as working in my
favor that is to say I'm playing for E4
and I don't see you know anything that
you're doing is very significant by the
way well there's quickly B4 and C5
usually
um
yeah exactly in this position with the
Rook on E1 I really I wanted to get an
E4 so badly Rook D1 B4 I'm assuming the
Knight goes here and now what you're
saying about C5
C5 might be you know perfectly timed can
I play Bishop takes F6 by the way C5
with the bishop oh and then yeah yeah
then I uh oh I've left E3 hanging but
you've left D5 hanging
so C5 does run into Bishop F6
you could well I don't you know you play
a move like G4 uh you're taking a big
strategical risk exposing your kids then
move here what's that Knight G4
T4 Bishop takes Knight E3 58 Knight C2
uh bishop and Knight are hanging so I go
right to D2 to defend the Knight Knight
E3 back he's done
ah 93 back Tempo Against The Rook the
bishop is hanging ooh it was interesting
um Constantine did not capture on F6 a
move I definitely thought okay was going
to happen but he can still do it yes
Bishop takes F6 but I'm assuming in this
case Knight A4 would be forced Bishop F6
Knight A4 Queen A4 Bishop F6 I can get
my knight
to D5 so your E3 and B2 bonds are
hanging true and mine B for nd5 and they
said seven pawns are hanging out so he's
done Bishop F6 I think Knight A4 is
obliged you definitely don't want to
play G takes F6 and just that ugly
looking structure I mean yeah
it's interesting do I have B3 a takes
and then Knight A4 B3
[Laughter]
B3 okay you you threw me off my stride I
got to give you credit for that B3 a b
now it takes A4 and then I guess Bishop
C3 yeah you have Bishop C3 just uh
a lucky one I must say I would when you
played B3 You Shook Me Up
a clock or the clock is the clock a
factor two minutes and 45 seconds for
each
uh so Magnus is probably calculating
wait you especially above six and still
an option and on Knight C5 then uh Queen
D5
Rook takes D5 I don't Magnus is
realizing Knight A4 Queen A4 Bishop F6
Knight F4
is not going to give him
I'm gonna say any winning chances
so he's he's desperately looking for
something where the imbalance could
favor him and I don't see it uh Miro
jump in do you see a chance for Magnus
here because I don't see it I'm afraid
the biggest chance was missed so once
again congrats to Nazi identifying night
G4 was very very good move after which
black would have had a huge Advantage
Knight G Knight G4 instead of c5s the
one that you were talking about right
all works yeah Bishop takes Knight E3
Bishop takes Queen Knight takes Queen
black is just better black is just
better and and then in the current
position let me see we do have Knight A4
Queen A4 that's still that's still
playable and uh very good move by
constantly very simplified yeah but he
found a very important move Knight F4
so as you were saying B2 is hanging E3
is hanging but B4 D5 and A6 A7 are all
hanging I was down on the clock he has
minute and 20 seconds against 245. yeah
because he's
having gone eight out of eight against
all of the murderers in this event and
he's playing against the lowest rated
player Constantine so he's really
wanting to go perfect you know making
that nine for nine and uh he's pressing
but no uh thus far Constantine has
played great and by the way Rook takes
on the board and I have Knight C3 yeah
that Knight F4 I didn't even see Knight
oh there's Rook d2. sorry I had a blind
spot as well I I thought wait a minute
Knight C3 or 90 you attack The Rook but
the Rook does play itself to D2
blocking the attack
okay if I take
on F6 and take
Rook the other Rooks coming down so I
don't want to invite that
before that's a tempo
night takes B4 looks like a safe move
you are covering C2 as well in that case
would you still play Rook D2
probably yeah yeah because I don't
really have a very convenient Square for
my queen
in that case
uh Miro uh
how good is the winning chances for
Magnus exactly at this moment does he
need some magic well computer says it's
equal and
you know not much you can do apparently
like Knight C3 might just force a drone
Knight C3 because Rook D2 it goes Knight
E4 you know and you keep trading and
even if black is slightly more active
it's
it's rook and queen versus rook and
queen symmetrical pawns we are talking
about so it's very likely a draw thank
you very we have some results we have
two results Yani pomnishi and Ivan
sarich have both won their games against
gukash and Anand
aha uh Vichy losing to Evon is uh
Knight C3 just as you prescribed
attacking The Rook Rook D2
no Queen E8 that's an option as well and
again onus is trying to go in the end
game Queen takes E8 that's winning oh
he's not winning a pawn but his Bishop
is better than the Knight rate yeah that
that was a surprise he could have played
Queen takes B4 instead of trading Queens
which he did very eagerly
Rook C2 and you're right in this minor
piece
wait a minute I thought he was going to
play Bishop takes B2 me too but I guess
Knight F6 she takes and then he brings
the other Rook to E2 and it's just bad
just bad Fair
now I think he'll keep his Bishop
because Rook takes A2 Knight takes F6
and rookie he goes for rookie two it
just uh a draw okay so now we have four
an extra Pawn it's a very pleasant
position why why go to the rookendan
yeah but
most Rook end games with one extra Pawn
is drawn so yeah unless you're in such
positions I can never lose
uh
uh good winning chances would you say
marrow for Rook ending but the but the
it's like the extra Pawn but also
the two Rooks on the seventh rank no I
don't think so I think it's just a draw
to be just a draw yeah I think it's just
a drawn
well we'll see it's Magnus we are
talking about and his endgame magic
right it's also 13 seconds versus
I'm sorry I can't see that 20 20 seconds
22 years for Magnus
okay well it's coming down once again to
one of the situations where just seconds
the players are wow it's 10 second
Magnus letting us time seep away
five seconds yeah he must just oh
Rook takes yeah
that was a good snap at Rook H4 I like
the way uh Constantine did that
F4
so he wants F4 F3 yes exactly F4 Rook F2
F3 and clock six seconds seven seconds
for each side yeah F3 is on tap Magnus
and now he's winning and now he's
winning now he's winning there was a way
to avoid being kind of paralyzed but
lupoleski couldn't find it and now again
the paralysis is setting it and he's set
up for F3 you have to play Rook takes F3
but then he takes A3
A2 and rook and he's nine for nine nine
out of nine right the Magnus is exultant
this is not the Magnus who was in in
shock in the Rapids when he went lost
back to back games let's jump to Fabi
Richie versus Fabi and we have
he has an extra rook and the bishop
right there's too many extra pieces yeah
exactly yeah Bobby won his game and do
you have an extra rook and the bishop I
was like where is it where's White's
Rook I thought we were going to be a
piece down right there's one more game
still going which one against firosha oh
and it was a draw I think
wow
quickly what can we say our eggs we have
to extend our congratulations to uh
Magnus just simply an unbelievable
performance a great exhibition Miro I I
I I can't think of anything yeah to
equal this this is just phenomenal
I mean this was really historic this is
this is unbelievable yeah nine out of
nine we have a million dollar prize for
the Bobby Fischer prize if you win
all your games actually I think it's 64
000. I'm sorry sorry I think I think the
idea was at one time we were trying to
get insurance from Lloyds of London for
a million that they didn't know how to
uh scale that what what would be the
premiums but we do have a Bobby Fisher
Price of 64 000 and we see a perfect
reason we're gonna make sure Magnus
isn't playing now we are not going to
make Magnus a wild card for the US
championship
we're going to assure the American
competitors
there you have it after today's Blitz a
day Magnus Carlson 20 points three-point
lead ahead Fabiano Carolina
we're still sharing the second place
exactly Ali Russia is in the fourth
place we can just say coming in today
this is a good result for him yep but I
mean who can catch Magnus nobody not
when he's in this kind of form this one
without a noun very disappointing he had
a nice rapid chess score of 10 points
but he's only scored three out of nine
in the first day of blitz dude has not
done much better but boy all of the
points at the very top there Magnus just
cleaning everybody
and let's jump to Zagreb with Christian
with a special guest
alireza just an incredible day for you
you scored quite well six and a half out
of nine how are you feeling right now
assess your day for us
yeah um for sure it was a good day but I
was expecting like more maybe like
um against Robert they lost a very bad
game and after that it was not I didn't
I was not in a good mood so
but yeah
um of course now for second is the spot
is open so we have to fight for that and
it's good for the whole GCT
standing because Magnus is stealing the
points yeah Magnus is not playing so
it's okay
okay well let's talk about this game
against uh Yan because I think by the
way you are always around 2 900 coming
into this event and throughout the day
did you know that was that in the back
of your mind as well no 2 900 is not the
goal for me another goal okay
but I don't know now I think maybe I
dropped a lot of points probably I don't
know unclear I think maybe I think it's
about even
um because everybody else is quite high
rated but Magnus is probably number one
now probably after nine out of nine he
was down 50 points he was yeah he was he
was probably his number let's talk about
this game uh between yourself and Nepal
because you said this was perhaps your
favorite one okay not this very special
game but he messed up the opening and it
was very convincing I mean
this was the
line that he confused because now my
Bishop goes to B6 and
I'm better here so yeah but against
Magnus he played Queen A5 against me it
doesn't I never saw this move
um
he played Queen A5 here and I I was
I played C3 and E5 here I couldn't find
how to proceed here I don't I wanted to
go attacking what it backlashed there
yeah and yeah I think right now you have
to like stay put maybe play something
like Bishop D2 or 92 92 yeah computers I
pushed before
yeah what was the mindset going into
this one you really wanted to stop it
and he was already on a streak he wanted
to catch yeah I lost only one game
before that also like I was five out of
six six out of seven so we were both in
good shape but yeah he was in better
shape even than me so yeah and that was
uh after B4 it's already very difficult
to recover because you have too many
weaknesses are going into the final day
you are four points and a half behind
Magnus what what is your mindset are you
still playing for a win are you still
hoping for that or are you playing for
second place right now what time is it
now I'm just playing for a second place
it's ridiculous to think about first
place because even Magnus loses four
games I'm down if I win four Magnus this
four then I'm down hops
doesn't make sense to play
for first but second is a good result I
think
if I manage to get it but it's tough
Fabiano is playing good and Jan also so
we'll see definitely a big race tomorrow
to the Finish Line we'll let you go get
some rest get ready for tomorrow and
we'll see you tomorrow thank you
thank you Christian thank you Ali razor
here Ali razor well Christian raised a
question in the live rating did Magnus
with a 9 out of nine result
surpass alireza and the answer is
no no
remarkable uh he was 50 rating points
behind and he still uh close is he's now
11 points eleven but there it is
perfection I mean you've got uh nine in
a row line them up what to say well
there's nothing to say I mean you
Miro jump in uh just
crazy crazy good crazy good yeah that's
incredible but yeah some more chess if
you wouldn't mind sure uh right
um you know lost to Magnus right yes and
you know why perhaps he plays the wrong
game but he was playing the Queen's
Gambit what you have to do you have to
play king's Gambit apparently because
Jan just swooped away good cash from the
board
look F4 D5
okay it doesn't look like King's Gambit
anymore but anyway
is the only one I believe from the elite
he also done a course on f4 on the
king's Gambit and he plays it from time
to time if not in Classics but in Rapid
and Blitz
and after say 15 moves all of a sudden
just look at the position I think 15
moves he's got absolutely dominating
position but we have to go back to
Croatia I was told because we might have
an interesting guest in the studio
right
Magnus we've said pretty much everything
that can be said about this performance
the final thing is to hear it from the
man himself tell us about your emotions
right now yeah I'm
this is
just very very special to me uh I mean
I've had good days before in terms of
score
um I think I've even like I've
definitely played better but at some
point I realized
that I could actually make it and I
don't think I've ever
like I've had stretches like in in
Poland where I had like 10 and a half
out of 11 or something but to win every
single game on one day I mean I have
ever done that before and probably won't
do again I think this is a record streak
in the grandchester almost for sure when
did you feel at what point did you start
dreaming about this
um
I guess when
when I had six out of six
um because I was thinking that well
other as a as black is a very difficult
matchup but you often get chances and I
thought like if I win that game I have a
very good very good chance
um so yeah I was definitely I mean
obviously it was like dreaming earlier a
little bit but that's the point where I
thought like yeah this could happen and
the UA Ali Reza talked about that moment
as well and he said that he did not
expect this move Queen A5 and he got
completely thrown off when he played
this move Queen A5 was that something
that prepared for him specifically or no
no I think out of Europe it's actually
like a move because I I played
um I played Queen A5
um
I played Queen F5 in the opening against
him in in Miami uh in this position and
I was pretty badly and actually Aryan
told me about that F3 Queen A5 is is a
move so I thought I didn't really look
at it further but I thought yeah well
let's uh
let's give it a try and it's always good
to
um to uh
surprise her opponent and
and it definitely felt from the
beginning that there was some special
energy about your game you came into the
playing hole first round with some
shorts and then you went and changed
what's the story of uh that flower is in
your hair also we yeah we saw that some
flower had randomly stuck to my stuck to
my hair um so I was just following my
routine and I usually come back from
eating at about
like a quarter to three or ten to three
and now all of a sudden my key was not
working
um
yeah they wouldn't let me you know they
wouldn't let me in the room so I had to
go to reception but there was a long
line there so I realized like I'm not
gonna have time to get the key get
changed and everything so I just
just came to the game as well and
changed after Magnus this is another
record you're breaking you've broken
many before what do you usually do to
celebrate if anything I have I have a
big day tomorrow so I don't think I'll
be doing doing too much but
um
you know this is yeah this is something
something out certainly remember like
one thing is
one thing is uh winning tournaments but
um yeah this feels really special
congratulations Magnus we'll see you
tomorrow thank you
thank you thank you Christian thank you
Magnus and here's his reaction magnus's
reaction to his perfect result of the
day winning every single game look at
him he's exalted I did it
[Laughter]
wow indeed pure joy
I liked it very much in the interview
because Christian asked Magnus Magnus
could you please put into words what
just took place he couldn't find the
words as a commentator I'm so happy
because sometimes I'm like lost and
dumbfounded
really our congratulations Maximus and
uh jumping over to you mirror share your
final thoughts of this historic day
capture them capture the day yes I'm
honestly I'm speechless it's it's uh
it's really something special has
happened because yes I've been
commentating for you know for quite some
years have seen like good results
outstanding results but this is this is
just comprehensible for now so I really
uh what could I do well Magnus congrats
do not forget that there is a round
tomorrow but yeah well done outstanding
result indeed all right lovely let's
jump to uh Croatia and to get the final
thoughts of the games and as we're doing
that I'd also like just to extend once
again our gracious thanks to our
sponsors uh Croatia's Foundation full of
life the super United foundation and of
course here in St Louis our
big thanks to the St Louis chess club
and Scholastic centers for everything
that you do for chess in America chess
in St Louis it's been absolutely
wonderful and uh back over to Zagreb for
final thoughts historic day guys
absolutely just a historical day I mean
there is not much more to say from my
part I've said everything I've said I'm
just happy to uh be here and present to
this historical moment historical day 9
out of nine in this type of field with
the best chess players on the planet
classical Blitz rapid it doesn't matter
it's just an incredible fit and
Anastasia you were in the plane called
to see it happening yes I will I'm so
I'm the luckiest here yes because I was
in the plane Hall and I witnessed it
with my own eyes it was really great
moment and Mark was he made like this
you know and people started to upload
despite the fact that this there was
still one game happening next to it so
like I mean he couldn't really uh you
know keep his emotions and he was like
so emotional when he left the plane
venue he couldn't stand he was smiling
he kept smiling all the time actually
and I caught him for a short interview
before you Christian and I published
them the interview in the our social
media accounts everywhere so I just
asked once again our followers to go to
our social media accounts to
grandchester and keep watching our
stories our videos and our posts the
more interviews the more capturing of
this type of historical moments the
better it was just once again a
historical day here in Zagreb and I hope
you guys are tuned in I hope you guys
were here to watch it and that's it from
us we'll see you guys tomorrow with the
final Championship day from soccer thank
you Christian thank you Anastasia Nasi I
can't believe my eyes it was just
absolutely fantastic so lucky that I was
here I know we're flabbergasted thank
you so much for joining us and sharing
your day tell your friends where you're
hanging out tomorrow the fifth and final
day of competition nine round Blitz
coming up can Magnus repeat
we have to say tomorrow see you tomorrow
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited